wir setzen nun die haushaltsberatungen
fort
für die heutige aussprache haben wir am
dienstag eine redezeit von insgesamt
drei stunden geschlossen
ich rufe nun den geschäftsbereich des
bundesministeriums des inneren und
heimat auf und zuerst hat das wort für
die bundesregierung die bundesministerin
nancy faeser
dankeschön frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren sehr geehrte
abgeordnete des deutschen bundestages es
fällt nicht ganz leicht nach dem
gedenken an kleine lässt es hier
weiterzumachen ich möchte aber noch
einmal hervorheben dass gerade sie es
war die in sieben jahrzehnten auch immer
für den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
geworben hat und darüber können wir
glaube ich gerade die brücke ins
innenministerium schlagen weil das ist
gerade dieser tage wichtiger denn je
meine damen und herren der krieg in der
ukraine hat dramatische auswirkungen in
erster linie natürlich für die menschen
im land und ich konnte mich vor wenigen
wochen ja auch selbst davon überzeugen
wie schwierig es ist und aber auch in
deutschland wirkt sich der krieg massiv
aus ich kann gut verstehen dass viele
menschen in deutschland dieser tage auch
verunsichert sind steigende
lebensmittelpreise hohe energiepreise
energie mangel und ja natürlich auch
durch neue bedrohungen der inneren
sicherheit wir erleben wie die russische
regierung gezielt des informationen
verbreitet um gerade auch unsere
gesellschaft zu spalten und ich werbe an
dieser stelle dafür sich bei
verschiedenen quellen zu informieren und
nicht auf das reinzufallen was im
internet auf zu lesen ist
wir sehen ein erhöhtes risiko von cyber
angriffen auf unternehmen behörden und
kritische infrastruktur in unserem land
und wir erleben natürlich schmerzlich
dass unsere sicherheit in deutschland
eben nicht selbstverständlich ist
sondern dass wir dafür auch etwas tun
müssen die herausforderung im bereich
der inneren sicherheit sind sehr groß
und klar ist wir als bundesregierung
stellen uns diesen herausforderungen wir
handeln wir investieren in die
sicherheit der menschen in deutschland
meine damen und herren
für mich steht fest auch und gerade in
schwierigen zeiten muss unsere
sicherheit absolute priorität haben
dafür steht der vorliegende
haushaltsentwurf auch ein er sieht für
den einzelplan das bundesministerium des
innern ein gesamtvolumen von rund 12,7 6
milliarden vor das sind 1 5 milliarden
euro mehr als in der ursprünglichen
finanzplanung meine damen und herren und
auch das sollte man dieser tage zur
kenntnis nehmen
in den jahren 2020 bis 22 hatten wir
durch die konjunkturpakete während der
korona pandemie sehr große auf höchste
für das bmi die haben wir für
vorgezogene investitionen insbesondere
im bereich der sicherheitsbehörden und
für den bevölkerungsschutz investiert
und das war auch richtig das war aber
nur möglich weil die schuldenbremse
ausgesetzt war ich will das ausdrücklich
noch mal hervorheben der haushalt 2023
hält die schuldenbremse nun wieder ein
und auch das und das will ich noch mal
vor heben an dieser stelle ist in zeiten
der unsicherheit eine form der
stabilität die gut und richtig ist
im einzelplan des innenministeriums
macht der sicherheitsbereich mehr als
die hälfte des budgets aus wir reden
hier von 6,5 milliarden euro und das
sind fast 200 millionen mehr als in der
ursprünglichen finanzplanung
besonders wichtig ist mir dass das
technische hilfswerk und das bsi sowie
das vollzugspersonal der bundespolizei
und des bka von den pauschalen
stellenkürzungen im personalbereich
ausgenommen sind ich denke bei den
verwaltungs beamtinnen und beamten
müssen wir noch ein wenig nachbessern
weil auch das hat auswirkungen auf die
vollzugsbeamten meine damen und herren
und es gibt selbst in diesen schwierigen
situationen stellen auf höchste im
sicherheitsbereich die bundespolizei
erhält 1000 zusätzliche stellen das bka
180 das ist ein großer erfolg und eine
wichtige investition in unsere
gemeinsame sicherheit meine damen und
herren ich bin dem finanzminister
ausdrücklich dankbar dafür dass er
diesen weg mitgegangen ist
wem aber dieser tage angesichts der
hohen bedrohungslagen der veränderten
sicherheitslage mein größtes dankeschön
gilt ist den mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeitern der sicherheitsbehörden und
zwar aller sicherheitsbehörden vom bsi
angefangen über das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz der bundespolizei
natürlich an vorderster stelle aber auch
gerade dem bka herzlichen dank für das
was sie in schweren zeiten leisten sie
stellt die sicherheit in unserem land da
und wir stehen voll hinter ihm
seit dem russischen angriff auf die
ukraine hat sich besonders natürlich die
bedrohungslage im cyber raum erheblich
erhöht das nehmen wir sehr ernst und
haben alle schutz massiven maßnahmen
massiv hochgefahren
ich bin deshalb sehr froh dass die
behörden die für cyber sicherheit
zuständig sind mit dem haushalt 2023 gut
ausgestattet werden hervorheben möchte
ich dass das bmi für die härtung der
netze des bundes jährlich 300 millionen
zusätzlich erhält für digitalisierung
und cyber sicherheit stehen insgesamt
rund 1,6 milliarden euro bereit damit
machen wir im bereich der cyber
sicherheit einen großen schritt nach
vorne aber ja wir müssen noch mehr tun
und in unserer cybersicherheit agenda
haben wir uns viel vorgenommen für die
zukunft wir werden in den nächsten zehn
jahren etwa 20 milliarden insgesamt
investieren müssen dass es geld viel
geld sehr viel geld aber
sicherheit gibt es auch in dem bereich
nicht zum nulltarif meine damen und
herren
und ich will das ausdrücklich betonen
die bedrohung putins in der ukraine und
die folgen des furchtbaren krieges haben
natürlich massive auswirkungen auf die
innere sicherheit und deswegen erleben
wir auch eine zeitenwende in der inneren
sicherheit und das weiß auch der
finanzminister meine damen und herren
in der aktuellen lage steht das thema
bevölkerungsschutz zu recht besonders im
fokus es ist völlig klar wir müssen
unser land krisenfester machen wir
müssen uns besser gegen bedrohungen aber
auch gegen klimafolgen wappnen und wir
müssen die bevölkerung besser schützen
der bevölkerungs und katastrophenschutz
wird deshalb gegenüber der finanzplanung
um rund 145 millionen gestärkt und es
werden 146 neue stellen für das
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe geschaffen das ist ein
großer schritt nach vorne meine damen
anzeigen
aber es ist auch klar auch hier müssen
wir weiter sehr viel in den nächsten
jahren investieren da gilt das gleiche
wie in der cyber sicherheit das ist der
bereich der natürlich durch einen krieg
mitten in europa sich verändert hat und
erhebliche investitionen in der zukunft
nach sich ziehen wird aber an dieser
stelle werde ich auch noch einmal dafür
das ist eine gemeinschaftsleistung aller
bundesländer und des bundes ist und
nicht alleine beim bund abgeladen werden
darf meine damen und herren
thw und bbk stehen im regierungsentwurf
2023 über eine halbe milliarde euro zur
verfügung damit werden wir die bahn
strukturen in den ländern weiter
modernisieren wir werden den schutz vor
chemischen biologischen und nuklearen
gefahren erhöhen wir werden die
notstromversorgung der kritischen
infrastruktur verbessern und auch in das
projekt labor 5000 weiter investieren
weil es so wichtig ist für die
verschiedenen krisen lagen auch
unterschiedlich gewappnet zu sein die
mittel
die mittel für das technische hilfswerk
sollen vor allen dingen der
unterstützung der thw ortskräfte dienen
wir modernisieren die ausstattung des
thws weiter stärken seine operativen
fähigkeiten
außerdem investieren wir in den auf und
ausbau der thw logistikzentren all das
dient der inneren sicherheit in unserem
land meine damen und herren und mein
besonderes dankeschön gilt all
denjenigen die im einsatz im namen des
thg es unterwegs waren bei ihrem größten
einsatz im aartal ihrer geschichte in
der bundesrepublik deutschland aber auch
natürlich jetzt in unmittelbarer hilfe
für die ukraine
herzlichen dank an die vielen vielen
tausenden ehrenamtlich tätigen aber auch
die hauptamtlichen des thws
es gibt einen bereich der sehr wichtig
ist für den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt und das ist der sport und
deswegen werden wir gerade in diesem
jahr gegen ende des jahres nochmal
massiv dafür werben die örtlichen
sportvereine zu unterstützen mit unserem
sport programm restart aber auch
natürlich mit einem bewegungs gipfel der
die zukunft des sportlers noch einmal
besonders hervorheben wird ich bin
dankbar dafür dass die
haushaltspolitikerin diesen weg auch
mitgegangen sind vielen dank dafür
vor uns liegen große herausforderungen
meine damen und herren das spornt mein
haus an der haushaltsentwurf für das
jahr 2023 stärkt die innere sicherheit
und er bietet eine gute grundlage um die
vorhaben des bmi in allen
politikbereichen voranzubringen auch mit
der einhaltung der schuldenbremse und
zuletzt bedanke ich mich noch mal ganz
ganz herzlich bei den haushalts
politikerinnen und politikern
insbesondere der koalition bei famila
schäfer bei dr thorsten liebt bei martin
gerster herzlichen dank für die gute
zusammenarbeit aber auch an herrn dr
berghegger von der cdu und herr petri
von der linkspartei vielen dank für
dieses gemeinsame unterstützen der
inneren sicherheit
die bundesjustizministerin nancy faeser
hier zu ihrem etat mit dem sie ganz
zufrieden ist allerdings muss sie
zumindest was der entwurf sagt fürs
nächste jahr mit etwas weniger geld
auskommen mal schauen was die cdu csu
fraktion dazu zu sagen hat alexander
throm sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
hörte kolleginnen und kollegen wenn man
über den haushalt des innenministeriums
etwas positives sagen will dann ist es
aus finanzpolitischer sicht ein
sparhaushalt aber genau das ist das
problem aus innenpolitischer sicht ist
es eine katastrophe
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen frau
ministerin sie haben gesagt wir haben
die zeitenwende ja wir haben eine
zeitenwende nur in ihrem haushalt ist
davon nichts zu erkennen sie kürzen den
etat des innern von fast 15 milliarden
euro um 2,3 milliarden euro auf 12,7
milliarden euro das ist innenpolitisch
ein offenbarungseid
sie fallen
sie fallen damit zurück auf den stand
von 2017 und nicht 2020 wo die
konjunktur gelder eingestellt wurden
2017 das war weit vor dem kriegen der
ukraine weit vor corinna weit vor den
fluten und ihr vergleich mit der
finanzplanung frau ministerin wird
schlicht hilflos wie mir sicher sie
haben beim finanzminister für mehr
geworden aber verloren ihre
amtsvorgänger haben jeweils steigende
ansätze in ihren haushalten einwerben
können offensichtlich ist bei der ampel
die innenpolitik die innere sicherheit
nicht so hoch angesehen ein frau
ministerin sie sind das letzte jahr
durch das land gereist haben viele
ankündigungen gemacht aber von umsetzung
keine spur sie können mit diesen zahlen
nicht das halten was sie versprochen
haben
wir haben natürlich eine zeitenwende
seit dem 24 februar so dass wir die
sicherheitsbehörden auch entsprechend
aufstellen müssen und auch aufrüsten das
sagt wer das sagen sie frau faeser am 88
bei der welt die sicherheitsbehörden
auch aufrüsten müssen aufrüsten heißt so
sie ein - im sicherheitsbereich von über
1,4 milliarden euro allein bei der
bundespolizei 400 millionen weniger und
das in einer zeit der migrations krise
und das in einer zeit von flut und
anderen dingen und wo sie ankündigen
dass wir einen schwierigen winter uns
haben frau ministerin das passt nicht
zusammen und dann haben sie ihre
weiteren ankündigungen in der bild
zeitung dass die kreis und hetze haben
sie heute auch gesagt bekämpfen wollen
und ihre weiteren ankündigung dass sie
insbesondere kinderpornografie
kindesmissbrauch bekämpfen wollen doch
überhaupt nicht umgesetzt auch beim bka
sparen sie zwar nur 25 millionen aber
sie kürzen dort und das passt mit ihren
versprechungen nicht zusammen sie sind
schlicht eine ankündigungsministerin
[Applaus]
und sie sprechen dann von einem neustart
im bevölkerungsschutz so jedenfalls die
erfindung ihrer pr abteilung sie haben
dabei etwas übersehen dass der neustadt
bereits 2019 begonnen hat ihr neustadt
ist ein fehlstart weil sie kürzen beim
thw um 40 prozent und bei bbk um 30% das
passt nicht zusammen sie war auch der
innenministerkonferenz dieses frühe die
innenminister am zehn milliarden euro
mehr in bevölkerung und zivilschutz
gefordert in zehn jahren und sie haben
dem zugestimmt jedenfalls haben die
innenminister sie so verstanden dass
diese forderung von ihnen unterstützt
wird sie gehen zurück als nach vorne und
das ist nicht in ordnung und nicht
verantwortbar eine kolleginnen und
kollegen
ist nur ein kleines beispiel
sie haben irgendwann diesen sommer davon
gesprochen dass ehrenamtliche früher in
rente gehen sollen
gerade da wo es darum geht ehrenamtliche
zu gewinnen beispielsweise welche helfer
gewinnung für das thw machen sie eine
vollbremsung praktisch auf null von 7,6
millionen auf 0,6 millionen im nächsten
jahr damit kann die helfer gewinnung
nicht mehr in dem maße stattfinden wie
es das thw und für einen residenten
bevölkerungsschutz auch notwendig ist
frau ministerin ihnen war die
schlagzeile wichtig als tatsächlich
ehrenamtliche zu fördern und zu gewinnen
und in der migrationspolitik sieht es
ähnlich aus sie sprechen immer so schön
von einem paradigmenwechsel den sie an
stellen wurden dazu sollen die
integrationskurse für alle von anfang an
geöffnet werden der haushalt sagt was
anderes da werden die mittel für die
integrationskurse gekürzt um 10 prozent
und für migrationsberatung für
erwachsene gar um 23 prozent liebe
kollegen kollegen von beamten
insbesondere von den grünen das hätte
sich ein unions-innenminister einmal
trauen sollen in einer solchen situation
wo wir mehr zuwanderung aus mit flucht
hintergrund haben in deutschland als
jemals zuvor und
dann frau ministerin verkünden sie einen
durchbruch in der europäischen
migrationspolitik beim gipfel der
innenminister im juni und ehrlich gesagt
ich war zunächst auch durchaus
beeindruckt allerdings im negativen
sinne weil ich schlimmeres oder
schlimmes befürchtet haben ein paar tage
später nach ihrer großen pressemeldung
siege dann durch das sich die
innenminister europas auf ganze 10.000
menschen geeinigt haben wollen die sie
verteilen wollen liebe frau ministerin
das ist kein durchbruch das ist schlicht
eine luftnummer angesichts der quantität
angesichts der quantität herr kollege
hören sie zu wir haben jeden monat in
deutschland 10.000 menschen die kommen
aus syrien afghanistan und dem irak im
august man es 16.000 erstanträge
wachsend insgesamt
132000 da haben wir die menschen aus der
ukraine darum wer die menschen ich hab
noch gar nicht angefangen weil sie doch
mal ruhig da waren die menschen aus der
ukraine noch gar nicht noch gar nicht
dabei die länder die kommunen schreien
alarm die ersten hallen werden belegt
sie sind sich dieser realität
offensichtlich in der ampel und die frau
ministerin auch nicht bewusst sie
schreiben presseerklärung wo sie in
blumigen worten danke sagen bei den
comedy brauchen hilfe wir brauchen
unterstützung sie brauchen vor allem
eine migration steuerung die dafür sorgt
dass sie entlastet werden und dazu zug
nicht täglich stärker wird und
noch etwas sie haben bei diesem
angeblichen durchbruch gesagt dass die
länder die sich bei der aufnahme nicht
beteiligen wollen sich finanziell
entsprechend engagieren sollen ich habe
sie gefragt diesen sommer mit einer
abgeordneten anfrage da musste ihr
ministerium antworten dass es im
ministerium über diese zahlung keinerlei
erkenntnisse gibt frau ministerin sie
sind mehr interessiert an der großen
schlagzeile als an der tatsächlichen
problemlösung
und ungeachtet
der zeitenwende halten sie an ihrem
paradigmenwechsel in der
migrationspolitik fest als ob wir nicht
das jahr hätten mit der höchsten
zuwanderung in deutschland als ob wir
nicht den krieg in der ukraine hätten
dass sie mich nicht falsch verstehen wir
wollen den ukrainerinnen ukraine helfen
aber beenden sie ihre
migrationspolitische geisterfahrt sie
fahren in die andere richtung als alle
anderen europäischen länder dort wird
nämlich illegale migration begrenzt sie
dagegen öffnen der illegalen migration
durch anreize und pool effekte tür und
tor sie begehen damit einen sonderweg in
europa und das ist in diesen zeiten
nicht richtig
hin zum schluss ein kleiner
tipp für ihren sparhaushalt wenn sie
schon neun monaten den sonder
bevollmächtigten für
rückführungsabkommen nicht besitzen und
auch ihren migrations staatssekretär
dann streichen sie diese personal
ansätze einfach im haushalt und sie sind
weiter liebkind beim finanzminister
herzlichen dank
alexander throm war dass qualität der
csu fraktion deren innenpolitischer
sprecher hier schon mal mit einem
vorgeschmack was dann kritik an diesem
etat zumindest aus den reihen der cdu
csu fraktion
geäußert wird was man dann mit in die
haushaltsberatung natürlich in einem
nehmen dort die firma müller schäfer für
die grüne
und kollegen liebe in ministerin phaser
vor 50 jahren
wurden elf israelische sportler und ein
bayerischer polizist von der
palästinensischen terrorgruppe schwarzer
september bei den olympischen spielen in
münchen 1972 ermordet die fehler der
deutschen behörden sind gravierend weder
ausmaß und der antisemitische kontext
der tat wurde bis heute verstanden oder
ausreichend aufgearbeitet
deshalb bin ich frau innenministerin
fraser sehr dankbar dass die das
versagen unserer gesellschaft und
unserer behörden klar benannt hat dass
sie eine unabhängige kommission zur
untersuchung dieser fehler einberufen
hat und dass sie mit uns gemeinsam und
haushaltsausschuss nun endlich die
entschädigungszahlungen für die opfer
auf den weg gebracht hat und diese
haltung
das möchten wir uns ganz herzlich doch
mal als münster im wagen an der stelle
in der vergangenheit haben wir auch
schon gut zusammengearbeitet an dem
haushalt und ich will so ehrlich sagen
wir müssen auch wieder gut zusammen
arbeiten an diesen haushalten es gibt
noch parlamentarischen
nachbesserungsbedarf
denn leider wurde die abmachung in der
bundesregierung nicht eingehalten dass
wir cyber abwehr und zivilschutz
ausreichend aus finanzieren weil das
nicht im sondervermögen mit abgebildet
ist das wurde versprochen im haushalt zu
machen dann gibt es aber noch
nachbesserungsbedarf
und das ist notwendig weil wir nicht nur
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten besser
ausrüsten wollen sondern natürlich auch
diejenigen die in katastrophen- oder
kriegsfeld unsere eigenen bevölkerung
schützen und auch das aatal hat gezeigt
probleme bei der bahn infrastruktur oder
bei den meldet hätten die können
verheerend die kann tödlich sein und die
klimakrise zeigt doch extreme
trockenheit waldbrände flutkatastrophen
das wird zunehmen darum können wir uns
doch jetzt nicht leisten massiv am
zivilschutz zu sparen wenn wir die
investitionsstaus jetzt nicht bauen dann
wird uns das am ende doch noch viel
teurer zu stehen kommen
und auch und auch die cyber residenz zu
stärken die kritische infrastruktur zu
stärken ist natürlich wichtiger denn je
denn viel wahrscheinlicher als dass
putin und konventionellen waffen
angreift ist es oft dass er
beispielsweise unsere krankenhäuser oder
unsere wasserinfrastruktur hecken wird
wir dürfen hier investitionen nicht
zurückhalten und daher müssen wir diesen
bereich jetzt auch noch einmal stärker
in den blick nehmen und auch im sinne
von krisenprävention ist es die
integration weiter zu stärken wir
brauchen integrationskurse und gut
ausgestattetes fachpersonal in dem
bereich nicht nur aus moralischen
gründen um unsere kommunen zu stärken
sondern auch um den fachkräftemangel in
diesem land zu bekämpfen
ich möchte noch einen letzten punkt
ansprechen der auch mir besonders
wichtig ist im koalitionsvertrag haben
wir einen bundes aufnahmeprogramm für
besonders gefährdete menschen aus
afghanistan vereinbart und ein jahr nach
dem katastrophalen abzug der truppen
sitzen noch immer viele menschen fest
und verstecken sich von den taliban wir
sollten unser versprechen sie zu
schützen nun endlich einlösen das
erzähle ich auf ihre unterstützung frau
fraser und sie kann auch auf unsere
unterstützung hier im parlament sehen
die aufgaben sind groß aber wir haben
schon im letzten parlamentarischen
verfahren fiel bewusst dafür auch noch
mal vielen dank an meine mit
berichterstatter insbesondere antrieb
und martin gerster ich freue mich auf
die konstruktive zusammenarbeit auch mit
dem bundesinnenministerium vielen dank
ich ja wieder schäfer war das viele grün
die sitzt im haushaltsausschuss redner
für die afg von da wird man dann an
diesem einzelplan in den nächsten wochen
noch einiges arbeit im november soll
dann erst der bundeshaushalt hier
endgültig verabschiedet werden martin
hess für die art
seiner wichtigsten aufgabe nachkommen
und sicherheit und schutz für die bürger
in unserem land gewährleisten will muss
zwingend eine ideologiefreie lageanalyse
betreiben und dann alle zur stärkung der
inneren sicherheit erforderlichen
maßnahmen treffen aber sie frau
innenministerin sie tun ständig und
beharrlich das gegenteil wenn man ihr
handeln betrachtet muss man ganz klar
feststellen noch nie zuvor war das amt
des bundesinnenministers von einer
dermaßen ideologisch formierten und die
realität nahezu vollständig
ignorierenden personen besetzt beispiel
islamismus es kann niemand ernsthaft
bezweifeln dass der politische islam und
der islamistische terror eine massive
sicherheitsgefahr für unser land
aufstellen die habt um den schlossen
bekämpft werden muss aber was tut die
innenministerin sie stellt ernsthaft die
arbeit des expertenkreises politische
islamismus beim bmw ein wer bisher immer
dachte dass sie lediglich unfähig
dilettantisch oder schlicht mit ihrem
amt auf andere weise überfordert wären
der wird nun eines besseren belehrt sie
verweigern mit wissen und wollen die
effektive bekämpfung des islamismus in
unserem land das kommt einer
kapitulation von islamistischen
verbrechern gleich und damit sind sie
als innenministerin völlig untragbar
genauso unverantwortlich eine wunde
widersinnig ist die handeln im bereich
der migrationspolitik sie beklagen
völlig zurecht ständig die gewalt gegen
wie sie es nennen quere personen aber
lassen auch für jahr in unser land
zehntausende menschen die aufgrund ihrer
meist islamistischen sozialisation genau
diesen hass mitbringen und in unserem
land auch umsetzen was jüngst wurde der
trans man mal der motor der täter war
und das ist inzwischen ja in unserem
land zu einem muster geworden ein bieten
dem wald gelegten verurteilter
muslimischer flüchtlingen hätten sie
diesen gewaltverbrecher nie ins land
gelassen oder ihn wenigstens abgeschoben
dann wäre malte heute noch am leben
nehmen sie das endlich zur kenntnis auch
die explodierende messer kriminalität in
unserem land wird von ihnen moniert was
sie aber beharrlich ignorieren ist dass
der anteil ausländischer tatverdächtiger
exorbitant hoch und zb in baden
württemberg schon seit jahren über 50
prozent liegt fahrt ist ihre
migrationspolitik verschlechtert die
sicherheitslage in unserem land von tag
zu tag effektiver grenzschutz und
abschiebung und sind das gebot der
stunde und das muss jetzt endlich
umgesetzt werden und hören sie auch
ständig legitimen bürgerprotest zu
diffamieren dass durch die einführung
des phänomen bereichs verfassungsschutz
relevante währung des staates jetzt
nahezu jeder bürger der die regierung
habt und überspitzt kritisiert in gefahr
geraten kann vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet zu werden ist für überzeugte
und aufrechte demokraten nicht
hinnehmbar und muss schnellstens
korrigiert werden denn die begründung
dass durch allzu scharf formulierte
kritik an der regierung das vertrauen in
den staat verloren geht ist ja
hanebüchen merken sie sich einst
vertrauen in den staat geht nicht durch
kritik an der regierung verloren dort
sondern durch ihre desaströse politik
die katastrophale folgen für die bürger
unseres landes hat und wenn durch ihre
fatalen fehlentscheidungen herbst und
winter für tausende bürger das leben
unbezahlbar wird unzählige firmen
pleitegehen und die arbeitslosigkeit
explodiert dann ist es das
grundgesetzlich verbriefte recht eines
jeden bürgers unseres landes auf die
straße zu gehen und der regierung auch
und gerade in schonungslos und direkter
form die rote karte zu zeigen und wer
diese berechtigten proteste da ständig
tun als rechtsextrem diffamiert und das
sogar präventiv aber gleichzeitig
aktionen von feindes for future oder
black lips männer aus ideologischen
gründen ausdrücklich begrüßt der
beschädigte unsere demokratie und
verhält sich eines innenministers um
gericht vor ministerin sie sind nicht
nur eine ideologisch verblendete
sicherheitspolitische geisterfahrerin
und damit eine glatte fehlbesetzung in
unserem land nein sie sind wesentlich
mehr sie sind eine massive gefahr für
die innere sicherheit und die demokratie
in unserem land je früher sie abtreten
desto besser für uns alle
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion dr
thorsten liebt
und er sitzt für die liberalen im
haushaltsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin frau
bundesministerin feser liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich find's einfach
unfassbar welche propaganda man sich
hier von diesem rednerpult in diesem
hohen hause anhören muss das war ein
neuer stiftung der haushaltsdebatte in
dieser woche
wir beraten
wir beraten heute über den einzelplan
des bundesministeriums des inneren und
für heime ist ja gut ich habe es
verstanden in einer denkwürdigen woche
diesen montag wurde
endlich und überfällig haben wir es
gleich danke eine vereinbarung zwischen
der bundesrepublik deutschland und den
israelischen hinterbliebenen des olympia
attentat wissen sie ich rede über ein
attentat von vor 50 jahren sie haben
nichts besseres zu tun als reinzureden
das nenne ich mal eine respektvolle
debatte verehrte kolleginnen kollegen
die entschädigungszahlung von 28
millionen euro die an erkennungsleistung
war überfällig und es war zeit nach 50
jahren gibt es eine lösung ich habe den
gerne zugestimmt im haushaltsausschuss
dass wir das gemeinsam auf den weg
bringen konnten am dienstag am dienstag
hat erinnern uns alle der israelische
staatspräsident in einer denkwürdigen
und bewegenden rede hier im hause dazu
aufgerufen die partnerschaft zwischen
deutschland und israel weiter zu
vertiefen diese partnerschaft mit den
anbetracht der geschichte die wir
niemals vergessen dürfen und werden
liebe kolleginnen kollegen immer eine
besondere seien niemals liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen darf das
gedenken daran aufhören aber
leider
kleider des antisemitismus immer noch
ein thema die anzahl antisemitischer
straftaten in deutschland hat sich nach
aktuellen zahlen
2021 um 29 prozent liegt über dem
vorjahr auf über 3.000 delikt erhöht ich
bleibe dabei was sich bereits bei den
haushaltsberatungen für dieses jahr
formuliert hatte wir dürfen nie
nachlassen
antisemitismus in diesem land mit aller
konsequenz zu bekämpfen so lange irgend
eine jüdische einrichtung in diesem land
unter polizeischutz stehen muss liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und deswegen
und deswegen halten es richtig und
notwendig dass wir weiter in dem
haushalt einen besonderen schwerpunkt
auf dieses wichtige thema legen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die einzelplan
beratung gehen schwierig in diesem jahr
mehrfach darüber gesprochen
wir wollen und wir werden als koalition
die schuldenbremse einhalten sie ist
nicht nur vorgaben der verfassung sie
dämpft inflation und sie schützt
nachfolgende generationen vor
übermäßigen schulden
deutschland muss in finanzpolitischer
hinsicht
stabilitätsanker in der europäischen
union bleiben und nicht zu vergessen in
zeiten von krise ist haushaltspolitisch
solidität auf die sicherstellung von
handlungs spiel auch mit der zukunft
viel liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
im innenpolitischen bereich in den
kernbereichen der inneren sicherheit ist
schon angesprochen worden
cybersicherheit bevölkerungsschutz
spüren wir diese herausforderung
besonders und als haushälter werden wir
uns natürlich diesen entwurf sehr genau
darauf angucken und sehen ob und wo auch
tagesaktuelle noch handlungsbedarf
besteht schon daher liebe kolleginnen
kollegen von der union greift es völlig
zu kurz wenn die der kollege kiesewetter
vor gestern oder heute der kollege traum
von einer schwächung wichtiger säulen
unserer sicherheitsarchitektur
gesprochen wird oder gar von einem
offenbarungseid in der innen und
sicherheitspolitik im gegenteil es zeigt
dort von der unkenntnis der zahlen
werden äpfel mit und verglichen nämlich
ein haushalt mit bauministeriums anteil
und einen und einen ohne wenn bei
berücksichtigung bei berücksichtigung
des auslaufens re konjunkturmittel ist
wie schon erwähnt ein klarer aufruf im
etat festzustellen und das ein wichtiges
signal für die innere sicherheit in
diesem land
wie schon angesprochen muss allein im
bereich des bundesamtes für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
146 neue stellen geschaffen wie schlagen
hat fdp in umsetzung des
koalitionsvertrags vor dass wir das
verfassungsrechtlich auch endlich
verankern dass das bundesamt zur
zentralstelle wird aber nicht nur dort
setzen wir als koalition schwerpunkte
das bsi erfährt ein enorm mittel auf
wuchs auf über 250 millionen damit die
dringend notwendige stärkung des bsi
erfolgen kann und dort insbesondere sind
die mittel zur bekämpfung von
cyberkriminalität und zur abwehr von
cyberangriffen hinterlegt auch im
bereich der netzpolitik verdoppeln wir
unter berücksichtigung von
sondereffekten fasst die mittel an setze
starke zeichen
starkes zeichen der handlungsfähigkeit
dieser koalition in schwierigen zeiten
deswegen sind wir gespannt als koalition
welche konkreten vorschläge von ihrer
seite in die beratung kommen werden ich
freue mich jedenfalls brauchst werden
spannende beratung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen vielen dank
der sagt thorsten lieb für die fdp
fraktion und auch wenn mit diesem
haushaltsgesetz bundesfinanzminister
christian lindner die schuldenbremse
jahr nach drei jahren wieder einhalten
will hat er in dieser woche doch in
einem interview mit der süddeutschen
zeitung beispielsweise gesagt dass er
eine erneute aussetzung der
schuldenbremse in einer notsituation
nicht ausschließe dies nur noch mal weil
das eben angesprochen wurde andré hahn
jetzt
energiekrise all das hat auch folgen für
die zuständigkeiten des
bundesministeriums des inneren und für
heimat sowie für den sport auch wenn der
name leider noch immer nicht im
ministerium im namen enthalten ist und
steht der vorliegende haushaltsentwurf
wird der sich daraus ergebenden
verantwortung aus meiner sich leider
nicht in allen bereichen gerecht das
beginnt beim schutz der bevölkerung vor
zivilen katastrophen und geht hin eben
das zum sport frau ministerin ich kann
ja ihre begeisterung für unsere
fußball-nationalmannschaft der frauen
durchaus verstehen aber muss man deshalb
gleich drei mal binnen weniger tage auf
kosten der steuerzahler zu spielen
unseres teams während
europameisterschaft nach london fliegen
müssen wir und hier meine ich den bund
das land bayern und die stadt münchen
die vor wenigen tagen stattgefunden
durchaus beeindruckenden european
championships mit rund 100 millionen
euro unterstützen und muss der bund die
fußball-europameisterschaft 2024 der
uefa mit einem zweistelligen
millionenbetrag fördern das alles das
alles wird die zustimmung der
bevölkerung für weitere olympia
bewerbungen in deutschland kaum
befördern das gilt im übrigen auch für
das militär sportfest invictus games für
die im verteidigungsministerium
35 millionen eingeplant sind
gleichzeitig und darauf kommt es an frau
ministerin warten die 90.000
sportvereine die für den schul- sport-
und schwimmunterricht verantwortlichen
die betreiber von fitnessstudios oder
gesundheitssport einrichtungen bislang
vergeblich auf jede unterstützung um zu
verhindern dass angesichts der
energieknappheit und der schon jetzt
spürbaren preissteigerung nicht wieder
schwimmbäder und sportstätten
geschlossen werden wie schon in der
korona pandemie fakt ist in den drei
entlastungs päckchen der bundesregierung
kommt der sport wieder einmal nicht vor
wo waren sie eigentlich in diesen
verhandlungen frau ministerin fehlern
die vor sechs jahren von der
bundesregierung und die usb beschlossene
spitzensport reform erweist sich
zunehmend als gescheitert statt endlich
dem sanierungsstau bei den sportstätten
und schwimmbädern mit einem überfälligen
vierten goldenen plan sport zu begegnen
wollen sie die schon jetzt viel zu
mickrigen förderprogramme des bundes
finanzieren sprich zukünftig kürzen
dafür sind sie frau feser gemeinsam mit
der bundesbauministerium verantwortlich
für die linke ist dass der eindeutig
falsche weg
zu kritisieren sind zudem weitere
kürzungen im innenministerium bei uns
leben aktuell circa drei millionen
geflüchtete geflüchtete auch aus der
ukraine
und dennoch soll bei den
integrationskursen
71 millionen euro eingespart und bei der
migrationsberatung 16 millionen euro
abgezogen werden das bundes
aufnahmeprogramm für aus politischen
gründen verfolgte oder auch von
ehemaligen ortskräfte aus afghanistan
steht in den sternen und es nicht
ausfinanziert
meine damen und herren der schutz
unserer bevölkerung hat nun endlich die
priorität die er schon längst hätte
haben müssen das waren ihre großen worte
frau feser als sie zum jahrestag der
flutkatastrophe im urteil vom juli von
einem neustart sprachen im
haushaltsentwurf ist davon nicht viel zu
sehen ganz im gegenteil sie ziehen
gelder beim technischen hilfswerk und
beim bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz
und katastrophenhilfe abstatt den etat
aufzustocken vor allem bei den
ehrenamtlich tätigen setzen sie den
rotstift an dass es völlig inakzeptabel
und wenn hierzulande gerade waldbrände
zum teil wochenlang wütend auch bei mir
im nationalpark sächsische schweiz
kürzen sie ausgerechnet gelder bei den
wasserwirtschaftlichen
vorsorgemaßnahmen bei denen es auch um
löschwasser geht das ist absurd
die feuerwehren und die weiteren
einsatzkräfte verdienen unser aller dank
aber eben auch unsere unterstützung die
realität sieht leider anders aus
löschhubschrauber fehlen löschflugzeuge
wollen sie gar nicht beschaffen 100
milliarden für die rüstung machen sie
dagegen weniger wähler in binnen weniger
wochen locker diese politik geht an die
absolut falsche richtung
stattdessen stattdessen wollen sie nicht
nur immer mehr personal beim
verfassungsschutz sondern vor allem beim
bundeskriminalamt und der bundespolizei
obwohl dort sage und schreibe derzeit
fast 10.000 stellen unbesetzt sind aber
immer noch mehr stellen die sie gar
nicht besetzen können auch das können
wir nicht unterstützen und abschließend
noch ein satz zum öffentlichen dienst
zig tausend beschäftigte arbeiten hier
in der unteren und mittleren bereich
und gehaltsgruppen und spüren schon
jetzt die
preisentwicklungen die sie haben der
aktuelle tarifvertrag endet dieses jahr
am 31 12 in ihrem haushalt gibt es keine
vorsorge für die absehbaren
tariferhöhung die wir unterstützen auch
das wäre ihre verantwortung gewesen dort
entsprechend geld einzustellen
herzlichen dank
andré hahn war das für seine fraktion
unter anderem sprecher für sport und
sprecher für zivilen katastrophenschutz
das feld alles unter den bereich des
innenministeriums und er hat er
beispielsweise angesprochen die
sportförderung die wird im
haushaltsentwurf in diesem einzelnen
plan für das innenministerium dass der
entwurf angeht zumindest auch gekürzt
liebe frau ministerin nancy faeser die
folgen des russischen angriffskriegs auf
die ukraine die korona pandemie und die
auswirkungen des klimawandels ja das
sind schon riesengroße herausforderung
keine leichte aufgabe unter einhaltung
der schuldenbremse ein haushaltsentwurf
für das jahr 23 aufzustellen und das
gilt insbesondere für die innenpolitik
den sicherheit integration zusammenhalt
digitalisierung politische bildung und
auch der sport sind wichtiger denn je
ich verstehe ja es ist aufgabe der
opposition sachverhalte zuzuspitzen zu
übertreiben zu dramatisieren aber ich
finde angesichts der multiplen krisen
die uns zu schaffen machen darf man in
politischen debatten schon ein wenig
mehr redlichkeit erwarten gerade in
diesen schwierigen zeiten
es ist finde ich auch für eine
opposition nicht zu viel verlangt etwas
mehr zu differenzieren und genauer hin
zu den anstatt nur zwei zahlen
miteinander zu vergleichen diesen
anspruch habe ich vor allem das muss ich
ehrlich sagen schon auch an unseren
koalitionspartner die cdu csu einerseits
heißt es da nämlich immer die
schuldenbremse müsse eingehalten werden
andererseits wird bei jedem bereich
insbesondere der innenpolitik kritisiert
dass der haushaltsansatz ja viel zu
niedrig sei das passt finde ich schon
mal überhaupt gar nicht zusammen dann
wird landauf landab über angeblich
skandalöse kürzungen im etat der
bundesinnenministerium hergezogen
verschwiegen wird dass der baubereich in
ein neues ministerium überführt wurde
verschwiegen wird auch dass mit den
konjunkturpaketen
wir ja ganz bewusst investitionen in die
innere sicherheit vorgezogen haben und
das in einer erheblichen somit zwei
milliarden euro von vornherein war doch
klar dass diese zusätzlichen
sondermittel zeitlich befristet sind und
nun wie geplant auch zum jahresende
auslaufen keine überraschung und erst
recht keine katastrophe und kein skandal
vielmehr muss man doch sagen gut dass
wir es gemacht haben denn wenn man sich
hinschaut was wir jetzt zur verfügung
haben dann sind wir doch froh dass wir
beispielsweise 700 millionen euro bei
der bundespolizei vorab investiert haben
dass wir bei der bundespolizei neue
schiffe haben in der ostsee wie ich mit
der kollegin bettina hagedorn neulich in
neustadt in ostholstein
betrachten konnte und das ist wichtig in
anbetracht der neuen lage in der ostsee
wenn ich daran denke dass das thw in den
letzten zweieinhalb jahren
zweieinhalbtausend neufahrzeuge für die
668 ortsverbände erhalten hat da muss
ich sagen zum glück haben wir das
vorgezogen denn sonst hätten wir diese
fahrzeuge gar nicht gehabt bei den
großen krisen lagen in den letzten paar
monaten und das das amt für bevölkerungs
und katastrophenschutz
hat auch über sondermittel in höhe von
300 millionen euro
profitiert beispielsweise für die
beschaffung von modernen sirenen um den
ländern zu helfen weil diese ja ihre
eigentlichen aufgabe nicht nachkommen
und da finde ich es schon ziemlich
unverfroren herzliche grüße nach
stuttgart und düsseldorf wenn die
dortigen landesinnenminister jetzt den
bund kritisieren dass wir das nicht
dauerhaft machen sondern diese hohen
sondermittel jetzt wie geplant etwas
zurückführen ich bin der meinung darüber
müssen wir reden jedenfalls glaube ich
dass der haushaltsentwurf in ordnung ist
er ist gut eine gute arbeitsgrundlage
es sind gute dinge drin im vergleich zur
finanzplanung gibt es auch eineinhalb
milliarden euro zusätzlich die
bundespolizei plus 1000 zusätzliche
stellen das bka plus 180 das bbk 146
also ich kann die liste noch weit und
lange fortsetzen vieles gutes ist drin
selbstverständlich ist der
haushaltsentwurf nicht perfekt hier und
da merkt man schon die decke ist knapp
vielleicht viel zu knapp aber dafür gibt
es ja uns haushälter und ich freue mich
auf die beratungen den nächsten paar
wochen insbesondere mit familie schäfer
und mit thorsten liebt das hat ja
letztes mal ganz hervorragend geklappt
wenn wir uns anschauen wie viel wir
umgeschichtet und noch einmal zusätzlich
mobilisiert haben jedenfalls freue ich
mich auf die diskussion ich bin mir
sicher dass wir diesen haushaltsentwurf
schon noch mal ein ganzes stück besser
machen können aus gute kann man immer
noch was besseres machen das ist das
motto für den einzelplan 06 in der
nächsten woche herzlichen dank
sakhir martin gerster für die
sozialdemokraten
und jetzt werden wir hierzu diesem
einzelplan eine weitere rednerin aus den
reihen der cdu csu fraktion das wird
sein die abgeordnete mechthilde wittmann
dieses mitglied im innenausschuss
bundesministerin kolleginnen und
kollegen lassen sie mich eines
voranstellen weil ich es glaube dass es
wichtig ist wenn wir über die zahlen die
ich jetzt dann gleich anfangen werden
selbstverständlicher dr lieb hat die
unionsfraktion das bauministerium in
sämtlichen betrachtungen herausgerechnet
und doch der liebe ich kann ihnen nur
eines sagen diese behauptung die sie vor
aufgestellten in der hoffnung zu retten
was hier in diesem haushalt eben noch
gerettet werden muss ist schlicht
unseriös und sie erinnert mich an das
unseriöse verhalten des finanzministers
bei dem entglitten haushalt 2023
meine damen und herren
frau bundesministerin phaser sie haben
vor drei tagen beim empfang der
sicherheitsbehörden gesagt sicherheit
kostet das sind wir vollkommen an ihrer
seite und sie haben jetzt gesagt
sicherheit ist nicht selbstverständlich
und auch da sind wir an ihrer seite und
ich sehe ihr bestreben etwas zu tun was
auch von uns mitgetragen werden nämlich
in irgendeiner form auch
haushaltsdisziplin zu wahren seriosität
macht sich auch daran fest und es ist
bedauerlich genug dass sowohl die
kollegin schäfer als auch der kollege
gerster von sich aus gesagt haben welche
nachbesserungsbedarf denn der haushalt
des innenministeriums noch hat ich habe
das gefühl sie werden im stich gelassen
von ihren eigenen leuten nicht nur von
den fdp ministern buschmann und link
tatsächlich ist es so dass dieser
haushalt natürlich und 2,2 milliarden
euro gekürzt wird und tatsächlich ist es
so dass mammut aufgaben vor uns stehen
nicht nur im bereich der migration und
integration sondern ganz vor allem in
der sicherheit für unsere bürgerinnen
und bürger unseres bürgerinnen und
bürger fühlen sich unsicher vor
straftaten und kriminalität das wissen
wir trotz des tatsächlich gestiegenen
sicherheitsstandards bei uns in der
bundesrepublik deutschland aber sie
fühlen sich auch unsicher vor
naturkatastrophen die diese zeit bringt
und von vielen dingen mit denen sie
nicht gerechnet haben lassen sie mich
zum ersten bereich kommen wir hatten im
jahr 2015 1,5 millionen flüchtlinge die
zu uns kommen im jahr 2022 verzeichnen
wir jetzt schon eine million flüchtlinge
aus der ukraine und einen weiteren
anstieg aus anderen ländern insgesamt
knapp drei millionen flüchtlinge im land
und dennoch kürzen sie ihn so wichtigen
bereich der integrationskurse um mehr
als 70 millionen und sie kürzen in
migrationsberatung ebenfalls noch mal um
13 millionen meine damen und herren
allein der bayerische haushalt hat ein
höheres volumen im bereich migration und
integration als der bundeshaushalt und
200 millionen höher als der
bundeshaushalt
das zeigt die pedal finde wir haben aber
stattdessen stecken sie 20 millionen
neuen behörden unabhängige
asylverfahrens beratung die ergebnisse
sehen wir verzweifelt vor ort die so
etwas bringt und wissen sie wo sie noch
kürzen was noch gar nicht erwähnt wurde
im bereich der leistungen im rahmen der
humanitären aufnahme in mit für die sich
diese bundesregierung so gerne rühmt
kürzen sie um 60 prozent um 60 prozent
ich kann sie nicht verstehen da chancen
aufenthaltsrecht dass sie so rühmen hat
ein mittelbedarf von über 70 millionen
euro kein
einziger euro ist in ihrem haushalt
dafür aufgewiesen kein einziger und
lassen sie mich vielleicht seien
inhaltlich noch mal etwas sagen wenn wir
menschen die fünften jahre da sind darin
stützen wollen dass sie eventuell jetzt
mal anfangen ihre identität zu klären
dann glaube ich geht hier etwas
vollkommen in die falsche richtung dafür
hatten sie zeit in fünf jahren lassen
sie mich weitergehen zum thema des
extremismus ja am rechtsextremismus
bringen sie kein blatt zwischen uns wir
werden mit ihnen fest an der seite
stehen dass wir diesen massiv bekämpfen
aber wieder einmal lassen sie auch in
diesem haushalt das auge blind vor den
gefahren des linksextremismus und ich
sag's ihnen nochmal wie schon die
letzten male der linksextremismus
richtet sich gegen die staatliche
ordnung und ihre vollzugsorgane und
dagegen in erster linie gegen unsere
polizistinnen und polizisten die nichts
davon haben wenn wir sie da nicht
stützen selbst wenn sie es sagen sie
werde ihnen stehen
und den ställen auf wunsch bei
bundespolizei bundeskriminalamt ist
richtig das sind wir der seite aber was
hilft es den polizisten wenn eine halbe
milliarde euro bei der ausrüstung fehlt
sie können sie doch nicht blank gehen
lassen zu einer teilweise hohen
bedrohungslage sie lassen sie im stich
wenn sie sie nicht ausreichen ausrüsten
und auch hieß es dieser haushalt seine
fehler
sie sprechen vom bevölkerungsschutz und
sie sagen auch hier würden wir
entsprechend stützen schon frau schäfer
hat gesagt das hier erheblicher
nachholbedarf ist und es klingt geradezu
zynisch wenn sie mir sagen dass dieses
alles ein ich habe den zuruf aus der fdp
gehört selbstzweck werde sagen sie mal
wo leben sie eigentlich es ist nicht
selbst unsere bevölkerung zu schützen es
ist nicht selbstzweck im
katastrophenfall zu helfen und deswegen
kann es nicht sein dass wir hier in
diesem maße kürzen 30 prozent beim thw
40 prozent beim bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
nur dass wir uns noch mal erinnern
dieses wurde einstmals von rot-grün
aufgelöst und musste unter der
unionsführung wieder entsprechend
aufgebaut werden und das ist uns
gelungen und
lassen sie mir hier noch einmal ein
ganzes stück weiter gehen sie wollen das
ehrenamt stützen das ist unser aller
aller bedürfnis das wollen wir und
gleichzeitig streichen sie beim ehrenamt
allein beim bbk eine viertelmillion und
ähnlich sieht es aus beim thw denn dort
haben sie von 76 millionen auf
0,6 millionen gestrichen wenn es um das
ehrenamt geht das ist ein schlag ins
gesicht all derer die wir brauchen das
sie uns vor ort helfen als wäre die
zuerst da sein wenn die katastrophe
passiert und die unsere gesamte
unterstützung brauchen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren dieser
haushalt hat frau schäfer ich kann ihnen
nur zustimmen und ihnen herr gerster
auch diese erheblichen nachholbedarf wir
sind dann wäre der seite bewegen sie
sich setzen sie sich durch gegen die
kollegen von der fdp vielen dank
nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen lamya kaddor
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen danke
auch für die mahnung an den
schrecklichen terror vor 50 jahren in
münchen ich möchte aber noch daran
erinnern dass heute vor 22 jahren mb
schimpf von ms von männer ermordet
worden ist und erst elf jahre später
tatsächlich diese tat aufgeklärt werden
konnte wir befinden uns in der
haushaltsdebatte begleitet vom hoch
angespannten und auch sehr dynamischen
entwicklungen und ich sagte sie bereiten
also übrigens wie schon zur krone krise
den boden für extremistische
bestrebungen akteurinnen nutzen diese
für das hehre mittel des protests und
ich sage es hier ganz deutlich solche
unterwanderten proteste sind zu einem
booster der extrem rechten geworden der
nicht unterschätzt und vor allem nicht
an spaziergang oder freie
meinungsäußerungen es hier zum teil ja
gerade gehört haben verharmlost werden
nach als staat ist es unsere aufgabe da
lachen sie jetzt als stark ist es unsere
aufgabe dieses unterlaufen berechtigter
protest anliegen besonders im blick zu
behalten
liebe frau bundesministerin vor zwölf
monaten haben wir die bundestagswahl
gewonnen und vor zehn monaten hat diese
koalition ihre arbeit aufgenommen
seitdem brauchen böse zungen wäre wenig
bis nichts passiert in der innenpolitik
und herr seehofers geist würde durch die
flure des bundesinnenministeriums war
das ist so nicht richtig ich war ja des
öfteren da die grüne stehen bereit wir
haben einen angeht im koalitionsvertrag
um eine liberale humane und den
sicherheitsinteressen unseres landes
entsprechen zielgenau politik anzugehen
sei es beim staatsbürgerschaftsrecht bei
der konkretisierung des aktionsplans
gegen rechts oder die demokratie
fördergesetz genauso wie bei der
novellierung des bundespolizeigesetzes
wir setzen auf prävention gegen
jeglichen extremismus auch auf den
islamismus übrigens ja auch dem liebe
kollegen von der opposition doch wer wie
ich gegen islamismus kämpft der muss in
der regel auch und er weiß auch
islamfeindlichkeit ist die andere dieser
medaille der einzelplan nun sechs mit
dem wir hier sprechen hat die meisten
kürzungen zu verzeichnen aber an
prävention dürfen wir nicht sparen sehr
geehrte damen und herren
im sommer reichen euskirchen allein dort
starben 26 menschen bei der schlimmsten
hochwasserkatastrophe seit langem 182
personen insgesamt was sollen wir den
menschen vor ort sagen wenn die warnung
gegen hochwasser oder stromausfall das
nächste mal wieder nicht oder zu spät
ankommen sollten das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz soll eine
steuerungsfunktion haben und dass wir
dafür geld in den haushalt einstellen
war eine verabredung doch blicke ich in
den aktuellen haushaltsentwurf das muss
ich kritisch anmerken kann ich das nicht
finden da müssen wir gemeinsame wege
finden hier zu einem fuchs zu kommen
aber auch andere bedrohungsszenarien
müssen rechtzeitig erfasst werden können
ich werde mir heute das gemeinsame
terrorabwehrzentrum in treptow anschauen
ich bin überzeugt dass wir am glimmen
beamte dort hervorragende arbeit weist
nur ihr auftraggeber geht es abgekürzt
ist formal keine eigenständige behörde
sondern nur eine kooperationsplattform
der mit der terrorismus-bekämpfung
befassten bundes und landesbehörden die
unter faktischer führung des bks für
eine verbesserte koordinierung und damit
für kontrolle sorgen soll seit jahren
wissen wir aber dass die von otto schily
im jahre 2004 als behelfslösung
eingeführte stelle endlich eine
rechtsgrundlage kraft schon allein zur
abgrenzung zwischen polizei und
sicherheitsbehörden ich erinnere sie
auch hier gerne in unserem
koalitionsvertrag
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
erleben eine verdichtung und
gleichzeitigkeit der krisen migrations
krise klima kiste corona krise
energiekrise und diese koalition muss
alles dafür tun um diesen zusammenhalt
und die sicherheit in unserem land
weiterhin zu gewährleisten
wenn eine militärmacht die russland in
ein land mitten in europa überfällt ein
cyber angriffe ausländischer dienste
normalität sind wenn stress tests
gefahren werden müssen der gaspreis
explodiert wird der politische monetäre
handlungsraum spielraum eng wir stehen
hier aber im wort der bürgerinnen
gegenüber für ihre innere sicherheit und
auch äußere sicherheit weiterhin zu
sorgen der zusammenhang zwischen grüner
außenpolitik und gruga innenpolitik war
immer schon groß er war vielleicht nie
größer als heute deshalb lassen sie uns
mit verstand herzblut und großem mut in
diesem winter gehen und auch um diese
haushaltsverhandlungen
das hat die sprecherin für inneres und
heimat der
grünen dann jetzt wenn wir markus möhl
für die afg
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich möchte meine rede mit einem
großen dankeschön beginnen unser dank
gilt den feuerwehren dem thw der
bundeswehr der bundespolizei und aller
weiteren kräfte bei der bekämpfung
zahlreicher waldbrände diesen sommer zum
beispiel in sachsen oder in berlin die
einsatzkräfte zeigen vollen einsatz und
geben ihr bestes vielen dank dafür
und jetzt komme ich zum unerfreulichen
teil dem haushaltsentwurf der links
gelben bundesregierung wehren durch die
explodierenden energiepreise milliarden
an steuergeldern zusätzlich in die
staatskassen gespült werden und die
vereinnahmten steuern unter anderem
dafür verwendet werden sollen um für
andere länder die folgen des ukraine
kriegs abzumildern will links gelb an
der sicherheit der eigenen bürger sparen
zu erhalten das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
112 millionen euro und das technische
hilfswerk
158 millionen euro weniger im
haushaltsentwurf für 2023 und das vor
dem hintergrund der vielen brandeinsätze
in diesem jahr entsetzen und völliges
unverständnis so kommentiert der
deutsche feuerwehrverband die
zugeschriebenen mittel frau ministerin
das kann ja wohl alles nicht wahr sein
aber nicht mit uns die sicherheit
unserer bürger hat für uns oberste
priorität
sparpotenziale sehen wir an ganz anderen
stellen zb bei hunderttausenden
ausreisepflichtigen asylbewerbern und
einer völlig gescheiterten energiewende
aber garantiert nicht beim
bevölkerungsschutz
für die brandbekämpfung brauchen wir
moderne löschen schrauber in
ausreichender anzahl da kann es nicht
angehen dass der bundestag 2009 10 zwar
die beschaffung neuer
transporthubschrauber für die
bundespolizei und damit den ersatz der
circa 40 jahre alten maschinen
beschlossen hat aber nach drei jahren
noch nicht mal die auftragsvergabe
erfolgt ist und auch immer funktioniert
hat digital funken einsatzlagen an
vielen stellen nicht störungsfrei die
einsatzkräfte in tunneln oder
funktionsgebäude wissen was ich meine
vor ort besuchen habe ich mir von der
situation ein ausführliches bild machen
können so wie wir unsere einsatz und
rettungskräfte optimal ausstatten müssen
so gilt es auch opfer von katastrophen
schnell und unbürokratisch zu helfen das
versagen vieler politisch
verantwortlicher während der
flutkatastrophe war tal hat schon
fassungslos gemacht dass von den
versprochenen hilfsgelder nach
inzwischen über einem jahr bisher nur
ein bruchteil ausgezahlt wurde reiht
sich in diese kette ein die betroffenen
brauchen jetzt ihre hilfen ausgezahlt
stadt gelegentlich vorbei schauen die
politiker dieser parteien die
betroffenen gucken und ein paar
beschwichtigende worte da lassen
ich sehe gerade die ministerin ist gar
nicht im saal jetzt kommt sie wieder das
ist schade vielleicht können sie sich ja
nachträglich im fernsehen angucken wir
haben sehr schön würde mich freuen
abschließend die ohnehin schon desolate
sicherheitslage in unserem land wird
durch den links gelben haushaltsentwurf
nochmals verschlechtert während für
links grüne ideologie projekte übrig
steuergeld angefasst wird kreist an
sicherheitsrelevanten stellen der
rotstift wichtige projekte wie bei der
bundespolizei und den dringend
benötigten transporthubschraubern kommen
nicht voran mit unseren
änderungsanträgen werden wie der
regierungskoalition druck machen denn
für uns gilt unser land zuerst vielen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
manuel höferlin und erst der
innenpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
sehr verehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren
die herausforderungen sind groß von
katastrophen über extremismus im inneren
bei analogen bei digitalen ich glaube
selten stand die innere verfasstheit
unseres landes die freiheit unter
größerem druck und sie ist nicht gut
vorbereitet durch das 16 jahre geführte
unions geführte ministerium
das ist so dass der haushalt aber auch
zeigt dass unter den schwierigen
voraussetzungen unter dem druck den wir
haben unter den jetzigen veränderten
situationen den herausforderungen
kraftvoll begeben können und der entwurf
zeigt auch dass wir die sicherheit der
menschen und ihre freiheit gleichermaßen
gewährleisten können und das obwohl die
zeiten schwieriger sind obwohl will per
niebler auf die steuergelder schauen
müssen als das in den letzten 16 jahren
der fall war an damen und herren wir
haben verschiedene punkte ich kann in
der kürze der zeit nur wenige hervor
kraus greifen deshalb möchte ich sagen
die fortschritts koalition tut sehr viel
mehr für die cybersicherheit die
cybersicherheit ist ein gebiet in dem
die das stark vernachlässigt wurde in
den letzten jahren das obwohl die
bedrohungslage ständig stieg an vielen
punkten der staat selbst nicht für
sicherheit im cyber raum gesucht hat
gesorgt hat und deshalb investieren wir
in ein echtes schwachstellenmanagement
wir wollen dass sicherheitslücken
geschlossen werden denn wenn etwas die
letzten wochen und monate gezeigt hat
bei vielen vorfällen das ist dass die
sicherheit durch schwachstellen und
damit auch die gesellschaft die
unternehmen extrem gefährdet sind und
deswegen investieren wir in die digitale
infrastruktur des bks und die
zusätzliche ausstattung auch der
bundespolizei denn der staat muss dort
mehr investieren und herren
auch das bsi als zentralstelle für die
cyber sicherheit haben wir vereinbart
das werden wir auch vorantreiben denn es
kann nicht sein dass cyber sicherheit
nicht koordiniert vorangetrieben wird
und deswegen soll das bsi als zentrale
stelle agieren in die cyber sicherheit
zusammen dann auch mit den ländern
koordiniert werden kann wir werden dafür
sorgen dass der staat trotzdem
eingriffsbefugnisse hat die vorhanden
sind und sie effektiv anwenden kann denn
es geht im gegensatz zu früher nicht
immer darum mehr und mehr befugnisse auf
den weg zu bringen sondern es geht darum
diese effektiv einzusetzen und dafür
steht diese koalition lassen sie mich
noch kurz ein wort für
bevölkerungsschutz sagen dieser haushalt
zeigt dass wir im bevölkerungsschutz
mehr investieren denn zum beispiel
erhält das thw deutlich mehr geld für 30
prozent mehr als 2009 10 dazwischen das
hat herr gerster ausgeführt gab es
sondern sondereffekte und deswegen ist
es wichtig dass wir beim
katastrophenschutz vorangehen und es
geht eben nicht wie in der vergangenheit
immer darum mehr geld drauf zu schützen
wie sie das immer bei der union machen
sondern strukturen anzupacken und das
unterscheidet diese koalition von ihnen
man kann nicht alles in der politik mit
geld zuschütten und warten bis die zeit
vorüber ist sondern muss dinge ändern
und das ist die strukturreform
katastrophenschutz installiert und die
kollegin sagte gerade eben so schön hier
minister seehofer hat am ende seiner
legislatur zeit entdeckt acht da gibt es
ja das bbk und er wusste gar nicht so
recht was er damit sollen soll hätte man
vielleicht mal etwas mehr früher
struktur angepasst dann wären wir auch
heute weiter und die menschen erwarten
dass bei uns wurde nicht immer nur mit
dem geld umzuwerfen herzlichen art hat
manuel höferlin war das der
innenpolitische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion und ihm folgte es hier für
die sozialdemokraten
elisabeth kaiser
[Applaus]
vielleicht erste frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin sehr geehrte
bürgerinnen und bürger liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die andauernd krisen haben
bei den menschen spuren hinterlassen und
sorgen weiterhin auch für verunsicherung
bis hin zu ängsten und das wissen wir
als sozialdemokraten den
sozialdemokraten sehr genau steuern
dagegen mit umfassen und hilfen für
bürgerinnen und bürgern und für
unternehmen drei entlastungs paket mit
einem volumen von 95 milliarden euro das
sind eine klare botschaft wir erhalten
als koalition was wir versprechen
gleichwohl ist es nötig in solchen
zeiten auch diskussions räume zu haben
und es ist gut wenn am sonntag in
thüringen ein breites demokratisches
bündnis von gewerkschaften
betriebsräten kirchen und
jugendverbänden in erfurt solchen
ortschaft es beunruhigt mich aber wie
rechtsextremisten die sorgen der
menschen ausnutzen sie hetzen und
versuchen unsere gesellschaft zu spalten
das zeigt sich auch in den zunehmenden
hassbotschaften und falschinformationen
verschwörungs erzählungen angriffen auf
die polizei bis hin zu rechts
terroristischen anschlag zu bringen und
das ist mit ein grund dafür wieso wir
die finanzmittel der sicherheitsbehörden
im haushalt des bundes des
bundesinnenministeriums in den
vergangenen jahren kontinuierlich
aufgestockt haben im haushaltsentwurf
für 20 23 liegen sie bei insgesamt 5,6
milliarden euro und das ist ein plus von
über 850 millionen euro gegenüber dem
budget aus vor corona zeiten und
sogleich schaffen wir insgesamt 1300
neue stellen für die bundespolizei
bundeskriminalamt und das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
um den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
zu fördern da freut es mich besonders
dass die bundeszentrale für politische
bildung in den vergangenen
haushaltsjahren massiv ausgebaut wurde
und um einen dritten standort in meiner
heimatstadt gera gewachsen ist und damit
sich dieser trend fortsetzt sondern die
personalmittel auf mehr als 23 millionen
euro steigen und der gesamtansatz für
die bundeszentrale liegt im jahr 2023
mit 87,8 millionen euro um ein drittel
über dem budget von 54 jahren und so
wird die rolle der bpp als kompetenter
träger von bildungsprojekten gerade auch
im rahmen des aktionsplan gegen
rechtsextremismus noch einmal
untermauert
gleichwohl ist es wichtig dass die
förderung für bereits laufende projekte
im zuge des kabinettsbeschlusses gegen
rechtsextremismus und rassismus auf
bisherigem niveau fortgeführt werden
können denn nur zusammen sind wir stark
für unsere demokratie die bewährte
arbeit der bpp ihre kooperationen
initiativen mit vereinen erzeugen
wertvolle synergieeffekte auch mit dem
bundesprogramm demokratie neben das an
anderer stelle im haushalt auch
aufgestockt wird und somit unterstützen
wir es so übergreifend
zivilgesellschaftliches engagement
engagement vieler ehrenamtlicher
helferinnen und helfern lebt auch das
technische hilfswerk das thw ist die
tragende säule im bundesweiten zivilen
katastrophenschutz und als
vorstandsmitglied der thw dann das
helfervereinigung sachsen thüringen dann
bin ich auch dankbar für die massiven
investitionen der letzten jahre auch aus
dem nun endenden
konjunkturprogramm für bewohner hören
die anschaffung von 1000 neuen
fahrzeuges macht deutlich dass der
katastrophenschutz für die
bundesregierung höchste priorität hat
das hat die bundesinnenminister dann
auch noch mal sehr deutlich gemacht ich
denke das ist auch ein wichtiges signal
hat die helferinnen und helfer und
kameraden kamera
und es zeigt sich auch im betrieb und 49
thw logistikzentren unter anderem auch
im altenburger land aber auch den
investitionen in die ortsverbände und
nichts ist schön zu sehen dass nach
langem warten der neubau und lehrer nun
auch zum einen ende kombination
analysiert wird und da ich vorher wissen
wir dass diese bausteine johann einen
gesamt ensemble wirken können daher
schließen müssen wir sicherstellen dass
die selbst bewirtschaftungs mitte der
ortsverbände und die ausbildung unserer
heldinnen und helden in zivil und
katastrophenschutzes forderung denglisch
abgesichert werden daran müssen wir
arbeiten aber da habe ich sehr großes
vertrauen in unseren haushälter martin
gerster und die kolleginnen und kollegen
ich danke ihnen
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
stefan mair
[Applaus]
sehr verehrte frau präsidentin sehr
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
verehrte frau ministerin sie haben in
den mittelpunkt ihrer rede den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt gestellt
ich glaube das ist richtig und im
bereich des gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhaltes spielt natürlich der
sport eine ganz entscheidende rolle und
die bereich des sports gab es in den
vergangenen wochen aus meiner sicht zwei
erfreuliche ereignis sind das eine
ereignis haben die kolleginnen die
kollegin schäfer und der kollege dr lieb
bereits erwähnt die aus meiner sicht
sehr erfreuliche einigung der
bundesregierung des freistaats bayern
der landeshauptstadt münchen mit den
opferfamilien des islamistischen
terroranschlags vom 5 september 1972 und
auch eine sehr lange gedauert hat es ist
glaube ich und möchte auch betonen wenn
die 28 millionen entschädigungszahlung
in keiner weise das leid der schmerz
trauer der opfer und insbesondere deren
angehörigen auch tilgen können ist
glaube ich diese einigung doch ein
wichtiges signal und hat aus meiner
sicht den eindruck hatte am vergangenen
montag bei der gedenkveranstaltung eine
befriedende wirkung ich möchte auch
betonen dass insbesondere die bayerische
staatsregierung sind sehr konstruktiver
kritik mit engagierter das zweite sehr
erfreuliche eigenes land die european
championships elf tage große
begeisterung begeisterte
friedlich feiernde zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer in münchen aus nah und fern
aus dem inland und aus dem ausland
schönes wetter große erfolge auch der
deutschen sportlerinnen und sportler nur
meine sehr verehrte frau ministerin wenn
wir weiterhin an der spitze in europa
stelle stehen wollen was die leistungen
im spitzensport anbelangt müssen wir
auch investieren und dann brauchen wir
vor allem auch moderne und zeitgemäße
sportstätten und wenn ich mir jetzt den
haushalt der des bundesinnenministeriums
ansehe dann wird genau das gegenteil
gemacht wir haben laut deutschen
olympischen sportbund in deutschland
einen investitionsstau im bereich der
sportstätten von ungefähr 31
euro in der letzten legislaturperiode
haben wir als cdu csu geführte
bundesregierung vor allem im
bundesinnenministerium den goldenen plan
wieder aufgelegt den investitionspakt
sportstätten mit 370 millionen euro im
letzten jahr und in diesem jahr und
einer ausgabe verpflichtung fürs
kommende jahr noch mal in höhe von 21
uhr 121 millionen euro leider haben sie
frau teresa jetzt entschieden dass
dieses programm komplett eingestellt
wird und das ist sage ich ganz offen ein
schlag ins gesicht von 90.000
sportvereinen von 27 millionen
sporttrainer sportlern in deutschland
und von 8 millionen ehrenamtlichen
entspannt
diese vollbremsung ist absolut
kontraproduktiv
weil natürlich selbst die 370 millionen
euro die jetzt der bund im letzten und
in diesem jahr zur verfügung gestellt
hat noch in keiner weise dazu beitragen
den investitionsstau im bereich von
maroden schwimmhallen von verfallenen
von nicht modernen zur neuen beiträgt
aber es war ein wichtiger aspekt und vor
dem hintergrund kann ich sie nur
dringend auffordern diese entscheidung
zu revidieren es gibt große enttäuschung
bei den sportvereinen in deutschland
über diese entscheidung bei den kommunen
und ich kann ihnen eines zu sorgen wir
als cdu csu als die parteien des sports
und des ehrenamtes in deutschland werden
nicht müde werden auf dieses defizit
auch weiterhin zu weisen meine
kolleginnen und kollegen sie haben dann
groß ihren neustart im bereich des
sports gelobt frau ministerin dieses
programm ist vom grundsatz sehr wichtig
nur es ist vollkommen unzureichend
finanziert sie haben vergessen zu
erwähnen dieses programm ist gerade mal
mit 25 millionen euro
dotiert davon den fünf millionen euro in
eine werbekampagne 1,3 millionen euro
verwaltungsausgaben so dass letzten
endes weniger als 20 millionen euro zur
verfügung stehen wenn man dies auf
90.000 sportvereinigung deutschland und
der bericht kommt bei einem sportverein
dort immer 200 euro an sich sorgt als
offen das ist lächerlich das ist
vollkommen und zu reichen
meine sehr werden kolleginnen und
kollegen wir werden weiterhin als
cdu/csu die parteien seien die sich für
den sport in deutschland stark machen
die auf diese defizite der
bundesregierung hinweisen und vor allem
es auch weiterhin dabei bewenden nicht
bewenden lassen nur darauf hinzuweisen
dass die dass der sport in deutschland
von der jetzigen bundesregierung
stiefmütterlich behandelt wird sondern
wir werden auch weiter da wo wir
entscheidungen mit beeinflussen können
uns auch aktiv und konstruktiv für den
sport und für die sporttreibenden in
deutschland einsetzen
stephan mayer war das für die cdu csu
fraktion
der einzelplan innen wer hier gelesen
wird das ist ja übrigens jetzt zum
abschluss der haushaltsberatungen hier
der letzte einzelplan dann erwarten wir
im weiteren verlauf am mittag lediglich
noch die sogenannte schlussrunde zum
haushaltsgesetz befördern das ganze in
die ausschüsse überwiesen wird marcel
emmerich jetzt für die grünen
der bundeshaushalt der entwurf vorliegt
er zeigt eindeutig dass der
regierungskoalition der sport sehr sehr
wichtig ist die ausgaben dafür sind sehr
stabil und wenn man sich anschaut wie es
um den sport in deutschland steht und
sich anschaut dass über die hälfte der
bevölkerung ist als unsichere
schwimmerinnen und schwimmer gilt und
sich anschaut wie viele zu wenige
schwimmbäder wir in deutschland haben
dann ist das eine gescheiterte
investitionspolitik oder eine
gescheiterte sportpolitik von 16 jahren
unionsgeführte bundesinnenministerium
hier hier hier investiert in den sport
und wir bringen jetzt unter anderem den
einstieg in der safe sportzentrum rein
und das was wichtig für die
sexualisierte gewalt im sport das zeigen
die vorfälle vorfälle beim schwimm
verband es drängt ist es dringend
notwendig dass wir hier was machen
und egal wo man diese woche hier im
parlament saß ihre redebeiträge hier
hatten einfach nur das buch von cdu im
sinne unseriös und durchdacht und
unglaubwürdig weil man kann nicht auf
der einen seite immer mehr geld fordern
bei allen titeln und auf der anderen
seite dann in der finanzdebatte meckern
und die schuldenbremse nicht im
geringsten anrühren wollen und keine
eigenen alternativen finanzierungs
vorschläge vorlegen das ist einfach
unglaubwürdig
was haben sie denn sie macht sich im
letzten 16 jahren bei der ruhegehälter
ruhig heitz fähigkeit für die polizei
ist nichts passiert dass die
it-sicherheit zu marode da steht liegt
in ihrer verantwortung und ihr
ehemaliger minister seehofer wusste
nicht mal für was die abkürzung baby
cast überhaupt steht das ist doch die
realität mit der wir zu tun haben und
diesen versäumnissen räumen hier jetzt
auf und holen wir jetzt auch
wir investieren in die cybersicherheit
wir sorgen für eine härtung der
it-infrastruktur und wir sorgen auch
dafür dass rechtsextremismus konsequent
bekämpft wird das sind alles punkte die
uns sehr wichtig sind und das sind
punkte wo wir jetzt auch in den weiteren
haushaltsberatungen auch als fraktion
vielleicht eine einen oder anderen
stelle noch mal stark nach steuern
werden und müssen gerade beim thema
bevölkerungsschutz zum beispiel aber
auch bei den beschäftigten die sich im
um die der digitale bekämpfung von kath
net tr kümmern da gibt es in meinen
augen noch großen nachholbedarf auch bei
den integrationskursen aber das ist
glaube ich eine art und weise der
politik die kennen sie gar nicht dass
man sich in einem haushalts
beratungsverfahren noch mal konstruktiv
und selbstbewusst als parlamentarier
oder parlamentarierin einbringt und so
verstehen wir unsere rolle aber als
koalitionsabgeordnete sehr wohl
und jetzt noch einen satz zu ihnen hier
da drüben am rechten rand ich finde es
beschämend dass sie überhaupt sich zu
dem tod von malte c äußern denn es ist
ihre politik sind ihre störche es sind
ihre es sind ihre skier sind ihre
störche es sind eindeutig diese störche
die diese freundliche politik
vorantreiben und diesen hass säen und
das ist dann auch häufig das ergebnis
ich bin sehr gerne frau ministerin ihnen
sehr dankbar und auch den vier
beauftragten der bundesregierung
regierung dass sie sich hier so klar und
deutlich geäußert haben dass sie ein
expertengremium einführen das sich genau
mit dieser bekämpfung von homophobie und
wir freundlichkeit auseinander setzt das
zeigt dass diese regierung da ein klares
zeichen setzt das ist etwas was der
frühere irgendwie nister bei diesen
themen leider nicht so gemacht hat und
dass es da auch ein ganz großer
paradigmenwechsel und das zeigt einfach
dass unsere begriff von innere
sicherheit ein begriff ist ja sagt wir
müssen alle menschen beschützen die
sicherheit ist für alle menschen und das
ist egal wen man liebt wo man herkommt
an was man glaubt oder sonst das ist
unser ansatz und so machen wir unsere
politik und so gehen wir auch die
haushaltsberatung an vielen dank
nächster redner für die afg fraktion
jörn könig
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen und vor allem liebe
sportler das parlament hat den sport
haushalt fast verdoppelt seitdem die afd
in den bundestag eingezogen ist
soviel zu dem thema welche partei sich
hier für den sport einsetzt im
kernbereich sind es heute 300 millionen
euro
damit damit wurde der spitzensport aber
gerade mal vor dem zusammenbruch
gerettet inzwischen aber sind die
warnsignale überdeutlich im zweiten jahr
hintereinander wurden zentralen
haushaltstitel etwa 30 millionen euro
nicht verbraucht es gibt also nach
jahrzehnten der vernachlässigung des
spitzensports und des sports gar keine
sportler trainer und strukturen mehr
welche das geld vollständig verbrauchen
können es gab sogar verbände die hatten
mehr hauptamtliche funktionäre als
olympia und perspektivkader es fehlt
also an nachwuchs diese fehlentwicklung
muss gestoppt werden
mehr geld vom bund allein wird das aber
nicht ändern hier sind die bundesländer
gefragt denn sport ist in der hauptsache
ländersache die sport und kultusminister
müssen jetzt die eliteschulen des sports
die sport orientierten schulen und die
kooperation von sportvereinen mit normal
schulen massiv ausbauen
jeder in den sport investiert euro hilft
den jugendlichen in ihrer
persönlichkeitsentwicklung bringt sie
von der straße hilft bei der integration
in die deutsche gesellschaft
und zahlt sich über die bessere
gesundheit mehrfach aus ein system das
menschen nicht zu mehr leistung
motiviert geht garantiert und da wenn
man sich aber die politik von heute
anschaut könnte man meinen dieser
untergang wird billigend in kauf
genommen denn uferloses gelddrucken
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen und
sanktionslos hartz4 sind doch der
garantierte weg in dem beispiellosen
untergang
wir sportsfreunde
von der afg werden insgesamt sieben
änderungsanträge machen vornehmlich um
die trainer und athleten finanzierung zu
verbessern immer noch gehen in
deutschland beim übergang von schule zur
ausbildung und von der ausbildung zum
beruf viel zu viele talente verloren
sport frei und wir freuen uns auf die
beratungen im sport haushalt
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
philipp harte weg
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir sind im einzelplan 6 und da sind wir
nun mal in der titelgruppe 2 in erster
linie beim spitzensport angesichts der
allgemeinen haushaltslage haben wir für
diesen bereich natürlich auch nicht
unbegrenzten handlungsspielraum wir
haben aber auch im vergleich zu anderen
bereichen eine solide basis um auf der
grundlage den spitzensport
weiterentwickeln zu können und
der spitzensport ist vielseitig und
bringt großen mehrwert für die
sportlandschaft die athletinnen athleten
sowie unsere gesamte gesellschaft und so
viele facetten der sport hat so viele
akteure und partner sind enorm wichtig
für erfolgreichen spitzensport vom dsb
den behindertensportverband die
olympiastützpunkte athleten deutschland
fes und et den trainern deutsche
sporthilfe bundespolizei zoll und
bundeswehr bis hin zu den wichtigsten
von allen die sportlerinnen und sportler
und so freue ich mich darauf mit ihnen
mit euch über die zukunft des
spitzensports in deutschland zu sprechen
dazu gehören höchstleistungen
leidenschaft und begeisterung dazu
gehört die integrität des sports vom
kampf gegen doping sexualisierte gewalt
oder spielmanipulationen
dazu gehört aber auch europa oder die
welt bei uns zu gast in deutschland zu
haben und wir können
sportgroßveranstaltungen von
sportereignissen wie gerade die
basketball-em wie die kanu-wm in
augsburg oder die open championships in
münchen lassen sich ganze städteregion
das ganze land begeistert und
deutschland kann sich auch in den
nächsten jahren auf vieles freuen unter
anderem auch die special olympics world
games die handball weltmeisterschaften
der frauen und männer die universiade in
victors games oder die fußball-wm die
fußball-em 2024 der männer
und ich bin überzeugt davon
uns würde etwas noch größeres in eine
debatte darüber gut tun und das sind
olympische spiele und paralympics in
deutschland
wir können eine große sport bewegung
allein mit den mehrjährigen
bewerbungsprozess ins rollen bringen
eine vorbildrolle in sachen
nachhaltigkeit einbindung der
bevölkerung stärkung der infrastruktur
und wahrung der menschenrechte einnehmen
und allein mit dem bewerbungsprozess
eine einladung an sportbegeisterte in
der ganzen welt senden die faszination
des sports bei uns hier gemeinsam zu
erleben
ein breiter diskussionsprozess der
allein einige jahre dauert kann der
erste schritt zu große gesellschaftliche
akzeptanz sein dabei können wir auf den
erfahrungen oder euphorie der european
championships oder den erfahrungen
bislang gescheiterte olympia bewerbungen
aufbauen haben wir den mut den
spitzensport auch dadurch zu stärken
indem er einen weiteren
bewerbungsprozess in deutschland
anstoßen ich freue mich die diebe auf
die debatten darüber auf die debatten
über die zukunft des spitzensports auf
die weiteren haushaltsverhandlungen auf
die rede unseres ausschussvorsitzenden
gleich vielen dank
nächster redner für die spd fraktion
frank ullrich
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen werden gäste
es stimmt mich noch etwas ganz
besonderes dass ich heute hier im hohen
haus für euch reden darf und ich muss es
wirklich gestehen es ist tatsächlich
auch meine herzfrequenz etwas erhöht
eliteschule auch im biathlon war
der sport bewegt uns und wir bewegen und
bringen mit 300 millionen euro mehr
bewegung in den sport gegenwärtig
befinden wir uns in einer sehr sehr
schwierigen lage das sind wir uns alle
einig und gerade in krisenzeiten kommt
den sport doch auch eine besondere
bedeutung zu
der
sportkonzern ist von respekt und
fördert das gesellschaftliche
miteinander
an dieser stelle möchte ich deutlich
sagen werden den sport stärkt und wer
den sport investiert wird in eine
nachhaltige zukunft investieren jeder
geförderte euro kommt den sport und
unserer gesellschaft und auch die
wirtschaft und auch der gesundheit
zugute der sport ist eine schule fürs
leben gut ausgebildete trainer
übungsleiter pädagogen sind eine
wertvolle stütze in unserem system
jede effektive investition potenziert am
ende den erfolg der gesamten
gesellschaft meine damen und herren ja
ja der bundeshaus ist sportlich wir
gestalten das heute für ein noch
besseres morgen deswegen finde ich es
gut und wichtig dass wir unsere kommunen
bei einer sanierung von sportstätten
unterstützen
476 millionen euro stehen hier zur
verfügung in diesem zusammenhang möchte
ich unserem haus eltern für ihre
sportliche einsatzbereitschaft danken
und würde mich freuen wenn wir
perspektivisch noch eine schippe
drauflegen können
die energie krise ist für uns alle sehr
herausfordernd erst letzte woche haben
wir als spd-fraktion ein starkes papier
in dresden beschlossen für uns ist klar
wir wollen den betrieb von sportanlagen
und schwimmbädern möglichst aufrecht
erhalten sport deutschland braucht
klimafreundliche sportstätten staaten
vereine spitzenleistungen aber auch
visionen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
lassen sie uns gemeinsam mehr mut waren
lassen sie uns gemeinsam
über parteigrenzen hinweg
für olympische und paralympische spiele
vor der eigenen haustür werden die
bundesregierung
die bundesregierung bekennt sich
ausdrücklich zu sportgroßveranstaltungen
und dieses bekenntnis findet sich auch
im einzelplan 06 wieder egal ob sommer
oder winter weltmeisterschaft in oberhof
oder european championships in münchen
wo wir alle doch wirklich auch sehr
begeistert waren wir können
sportgroßveranstaltungen sehr geehrte
frau ministerin vielen dank dass sie den
sport zur chefinnen sache gemacht haben
und weiter auch machen wollen für mich
ist der sport eine musik die sachen
herzensangelegenheit ich persönlich
dürfte insgesamt seien zwölf olympischen
spielen teilnehmen
und wenn internationale sport
großveranstaltungen strikt an die
beachtung von un leitprinzipien für
wirtschaft menschenrechte und
nachhaltigkeit geknüpft sind
dann sind sie eine win win situation
kommen
es geht auch um eine flamme zu entzünden
die uns als gesellschaft auch noch näher
zusammenbringt die bürgerinnen und
bürger unseres landes möchte nicht
wissen was nicht geht sondern sie
möchten eigentlich wissen was möglich
ist und ich sage in jeder krise steckt
auch eine chance wir sollten sie
gemeinsam nutzen denn zusammen sind wir
stärker
und wenn wir mal wieder groß denken
wollen müssen wir alle im kleinen
beginnen das engagement und es wurde
bereits schon angedeutet von über 90.000
vereinen in deutschland ist unbezahlbar
24 millionen vereinsmitglieder nicht
doch etwas geschrumpft auch und
unzählige ehrenamtliche bildenden kind
in unserer gesellschaft mit dem riestern
programm setzen wir im bund ein
wichtiges zeichen hier bin ich unsere
ministerin menschen sehr dankbar dafür
gemeinsam mit dem dmsb und
gesundheitsministerium im dezember
zeitnah in bewegungsgefühl gestalten die
spitze braucht die breite und die breite
braucht die spitze wir oder wer
erfolgreich sein möchte braucht starke
partner
der dmsb seine spitzenverbände der
deutsche behindertenverband die athleten
deutschland die sportministerkonferenz
der sportausschuss des städtetages und
der sportausschuss des deutschen
bundestages als auch
das bmi
wir alle brennen für den sport und
teilen die gemeinsamkeit sport
deutschland weiter voranzubringen
deswegen gehört aus meiner sicht ähnlich
wie es auch in vielen anderen ländern
erfolgreich praktiziert wird der sport
ins grundgesetz
sehr geehrte damen und herren lassen sie
uns motiviert ins neue jahrzehnt starten
motiviert diese gesellschaft mit booms
gestalten ich bedanke mich für eure
aufmerksamkeit
frank ullrich war das für die spd und
das dashboard eine herzensangelegenheit
das ist das glaubt man dem ehemaligen
biathleten und unter anderem gold mit
einem gewinn ich bin ich seit heute mal
durchgehen ihr puls hat gezeigt dass sie
als leistungssportler noch an der zeit
arbeiten müssen aber zu ihrer ersten
rede hier im deutschen bundestag
gratuliere ich ihnen recht herzlich
also das war seine erste rede und uns
hat uns auch schon gewundert warum er so
lange reden darf aber das ist hier doch
dann muss im bundestag dass man dort bei
den ersten reden etwas milde walten
lässt und er jedoch deutlich zwei
minuten überziehen konnte für den
nächsten redner gilt das sind nicht mehr
marc heinrich mann für die cdu/csu
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen vor zwei
tagen beim parlamentarischen arm der
reserve der bundeswehr die
verteidigungsministerin den satz geprägt
haushalt sei der test ob eine regierung
nicht nur redet sondern auch handelt aus
ihrem mund entbehrt es nicht einer
gewissen ironie war glaube ich mancher
in ihrem ministerium oder in der ukraine
froh wäre wenn sie wenigstens mal mit
ihm reden würde aber der satz ist ja
richtig
und im resümee müssen wir festhalten
dass auch veh sieht diesen test leider
mich bestehen ganz im gegenteil sie
legen ihrem hause mit diesem entwurf
handschellen in zentralen feldern an
integration migration die kürzung in
einer zeit wo die migrations zahlen
dramatisch ansteigen sicherlich ein
falsches signal genauso wie die
auflösung des expertenkreises
politischer islamismus und beim thema
thw hätten einige jetzt glaube ich hier
aus den koalitionsfraktionen mal den
tonfall etwas drosseln sollen denn die
kürzungen beim thw insgesamt fast 160
millionen kommen ja im wesentlichen an
bei mehren und bei der ausbildung der
ernannt und das ist ja und da besteht ja
auch gegen der ampel keine einigkeit
sondern es ist ja so dass schon
vernehmen zu übernehmen ist von sehr weh
ortsverbänden das aus der spd das signal
kommt man hätte ja mehr getan aber der
böse finanzminister habe das ja nicht
zugelassen die einigkeit ist sehr groß
aber wenn wir alle der meinung sind
bevölkerungs und katastrophenschutz in
diesen zeiten hat oberste priorität
dann erwarten wir glaube ich alle zu
recht dass dann noch die innenministerin
zum finanzminister geht wenn er das
nicht versteht bereits schuldig auftritt
und sagt wir brauchen das geld für das
ehrenamt im bevölkerungsschutz und
fräser sie haben ja auch viele richtige
ansätze und mit der cyber-sicherheit
agenda haben sie ja auch wichtige punkte
gesetz ist es richtig unternehmen vor
erpresserischen hackern zu schützen es
ist richtig die kritisch vor dem kollaps
zu bewahren bürger sicher im netz surfen
zu lassen und dann kommt der haushalt
und dann sage nicht nur ich dass es
ambitionslos und dann schreibt zum
beispiel der tagesspiegel dass ein
ambitionierter plan im haushalt ist
davon wenig zu sehen oder aber viel
agenda wenig stellen und wenig stellen
das bsi genannt das bsi soll eine
zentralstelle werden deutschlandweit
federführend agieren die
abstimmungsprozesse werden ein ausmaß
annehmen dass wahrscheinlich nicht mal
eben zu bewältigen ist und
stellenzuwachs in diesem bereich
fehlanzeige
nur so wird man den herausforderungen
hier sicherlich nicht gerechnet
und auch das bka auch wenn es 167 neue
stellen geben soll aus den reihen des
bka wird gesagt menschen wissen noch gar
nicht ob die stellen für die aufgaben
die wir im bereich cybercrime leisten
sollen ob die stelle überhaupt reichen
das bild was sich hier zeichnet ist da
wird einfach mal personal aus gerotzt in
zahlen stärke und keiner weiß was dieses
kanal machen soll ob es reicht ob es
ausreicht dass es blindflug sie wissen
nicht wo sie hin wollen und genau das
sagt dieser haushaltslage
und ich will immer zwei beispiele kurz
an essen die verkehrsdaten speicherung
und wir sind uns einig jedenfalls die
union mit ihnen glaube ich dass wir
diesen ekelhaften sumpf der
kinderschänder in deutschland endlich
trocken legen wollen und genau das haben
sie im april diesen jahres gesagt wir
brauchen zitat sogar die
vorratsdatenspeicherung ihr zitat wenn
hat die ampel die ampel fraktionen haben
dann innerlich getobt und dann haben sie
irgendwann mal aufgebaut haben sagt ja
so habe ich vielleicht gar nicht gemeint
schrieb die presse nur noch bestimmte ip
adressen sollen gespeichert werden wenn
wir aber der meinung sind dass wir gegen
kinderschänder in deutschland aktiv
vorgehen wollen dass sie den
ermittlungsbehörden auch die instrumente
an die hand geben wollen dann haben wir
einen weg hier geboten wir haben am
24.06 den deutschen bundestag als union
einen antrag vorgelegt das aber
kategorisch abgelehnt und stattdessen
aber man könnte ja meinen ok bekehrt
anderer weg alles gut
stattdessen aber jetzt vor wenigen tagen
beim herbstfest der sicherheitsbehörden
die aussage die wiedereinführung sei
aber im kampf gegen kindesmissbrauch
unbedingt erforderlich und es müssen den
ermittlern die instrumente an die hand
gegeben werden vor allem ministerin ich
erwarte jetzt auch mal dass den worten
taten folgen und dass sie auch ihre
fraktionen mal auf linie bringen wo
wollen sie denn eigentlich hin das ist
kein kurs und das hilft auch nicht
unseren ermittlungsbehörden und im
bereich aktiver cyber abwehr haben wir
ja das gleiche thema er würde man von
hacks geredet ich bin ein bisschen
verwirrt weil ehrlicherweise aktive
cyber abwehr auch mehr ist als der hack
beck aber aus ihrem mund soll das zitat
kommen im april gegeben das heck becks
unvermeidbar sein und fragen der
sicherheit wir für man nicht ideologisch
angehen im juli dann aber berichtet die
presse frau feser lehnt pack becks ab
im april haben sie dann angekündigt bei
der grundgesetzänderung die notwendig
ist zum beispiel zentralstelle bse sie
wollen zügig auf die union zu gehen um
die zwei drittel mehr zu beschaffen
jetzt ist fraglich ob die
grundgesetzänderung uns da irgendwie
hilfe ich weiß es gibt viele skeptiker
aber wenn sie im april sagen sie wollen
schnell auf die union zu gehen und ist
bis heute offenbar nicht passiert ist
dann frage ich mich was ist denn ihre
definition von schnell im bereich
kriminalitätsbekämpfung im netz
und ob verkehrs datenspeicherung
cybercrime sie haben jede position
mittlerweile mindestens einmal geändert
und wieder zurück und eine umsetzung ist
bis heute kategorisch fehlanzeige und es
wird aber oft geschrieben wenn man sie
informieren möchte cyber die unsichtbare
gefahr
doch die größte gefahr für die menschen
und die sicherheit in diesem lande ist
eine unsichtbare innenministerin in
diesem feld
und es ist ja auch mein offenes
geheimnis dass sie dieses ressort nicht
gewollt haben das nicht ihre
leidenschaft bauen dass ihr ziel
vielleicht etwas weiter südlich in
hessen liegt der haushalt des
bundesinnenministeriums sinkt um 2,2
milliarden euro kann man ja sagen klar
wir sehen sein wo man sparen muss aber
ich erwarte jetzt auch
schwerpunktsetzung ich erwarte
durchsetzung autorität auch die
einordnung der ampel fraktionen
zumindest kompromisse die man bestreitet
im zuge von sicherheit die wir brauchen
in diesem land wenn der haushalt der
tester handlungsfähigkeit war dann haben
sie ihn auf jeden fall nicht bestanden
und das ist schlecht für die sicherheit
in diesem land es gibt sehr viel
nachzubessern an diesem haushalt vielen
dank
nächster redner ist der abgeordnete
stefan seite
vielen dank frau präsidentin neun
kolleginnen und kollegen vor der
sommerpause haben wir hier im plenum und
im innenausschuss über die konsequenzen
der flutkatastrophe im aartal beraten
dort traf die kraft des wassers auf
einen überforderten bevölkerungsschutz
eine kraft und einige fahrer die die
menschen von nord und ostsee nur allzu
gut kennen deshalb vermisse ich als
vertreter einer küstenregion im bereich
bevölkerungsschutz einen wichtigen teil
nämlich den küstenschutz da ich die
dämme schleusen aber auch
katastrophenhilfe und ausrüstung
schützen land und leute küstenschutz ist
auch im bevölkerungsschutz
wir wissen dass aufgrund des weltweiten
temperaturanstiegs die häufigkeit von
hochwasser stetig steigen wird in 80
jahren auf 110 hochwasser jährlich an
unsere ostküste und an der westküste auf
30 im jahr unsere kinder werden mit
dieser massiven bedrohung leben müssen
der meeresspiegel an der ostküste wird
um einen halben meter ansteigen wenn wir
nicht in ausrüstungen im küstenschutz
und bevölkerungsschutz investieren dann
brauchen sie bald nicht mehr nach
venedig reisen steht wie flensburg
schleswig rendsburg oder auch viel tun
es dann auch ob sie dann noch so
sehenswert sind bezweifle ich sehr
entschuldigen sie meine norddeutschen
galgenhumor aber ist unterstreicht die
zunehmende angst der menschen in meiner
heimat liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
unsere nachbarländer machen es uns vor
während dort gerade ordentlich gebechert
nach geschaufelt und ausgebildet wird
machen wir leider zu wenig in diesem
bereich liebe ministerin feser wenn ich
diese gefahr gerade in ihrem einzelplan
anspreche dann weil die zuständigkeit
der bundesregierung in dieser frage
unklar ist denn bei ihnen im
innenministerium nicht der
bevölkerungsschutz und im
landwirtschaftsministerium liegen teile
des küstenschutzes ich fordere sie auf
machen sie jetzt klare kante sorgen sie
für zusammenarbeit strukturen denn
später werden wir keine zeit für
kompetenzgerangel haben denn eines ist
gewiss das nächste hochwasser wird
kommen und ja wir müssen weiter auf die
kompetenzen der menschen vor ort
zugreifen die dringlichen investitionen
können sie aber nicht alleine stemmen es
kann auch nicht sein dass reiche
kommunen an unserer westküste sich neue
klima deiche und küstenschutz und
bevölkerungsschutz leisten können wenn
der ärmeren nachbar abläuft ich erwarte
von der bundesregierung in zukunft mehr
und ausreichende investitionen und eine
klare aufgabenverteilung im bereich
bevölkerungsschutz und küstenschutz die
menschen im norden setzen auf sie vielen
dank
stefan s seidler war dass er ist
mitglied des südschleswigschen
wählerverbandes
deswegen fraktionslos und deswegen auch
als beratendes mitglied im ausschuss für
inneres und heimat näher und eckhard
spricht jetzt für bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte kolleginnen kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger in europa ist
krieg und auch wir merken die
auswirkungen dieses krieges jeden tag
ihr leben die aushilfen ökonomisch mit
angriffen auf unsere kritische
infrastruktur und durch gezielte
desinformation in unserer gesellschaft
für diese hybriden bedrohungsszenarien
brauchen wir den zivilschutz und
angesichts der situation in europa bin
ich der festen überzeugung dass er
deshalb jetzt unseren zivilschutz des
thw unser bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz noch mehr finanziell
stärken müssen
denn wir wissen nicht was noch kommt
eine breite und gute vorbereitung lässt
uns handlungsbereit sagen egal auf
welcher welche herausforderung auf uns
warten wenn ultima ratio kommt müssen
wir vorbereitet sein
für diese vorbereitung müssen wir jetzt
mehr investieren einige kurze beispiele
aus dem haushalt im haushaltsentwurf
kürzen nur unter anderem die
krisenkommunikation und die selbsthilfe
selbsthilfe und dem power nennt das kann
ängste abbauen die aus unsicherheit
resultieren und jeder einzelne von uns
kann souveräner in der krise handeln
geschickte krisenkommunikation
ermöglicht solidarität auch in der krise
niemand ist geholfen wenn lokal das
stromnetz zusammen bricht bei jeder
dachte jetzt den heizlüfter einschalten
das ist eine super idee
deshalb sind diese beiden haushalts
punkte entscheidend für gute
vorbereitung für diesen winter da müssen
wir nachbessern
hubschrauber dem zivilschutz fehlen
adäquate luft fähigkeiten kranken und
materialtransport wären dringend
notwendig gerade verlassen wir uns oft
auf die bundeswehr doch was ist wenn die
hubschrauber der bundeswehr andere
aufgaben erledigen müssen deshalb müssen
wir ganz konkret über mittlere
transporthubschrauber für den
zivilschutz diskutieren und wie weit die
szenarien reichen können das zeigt die
situation am größten europäischen
atomkraftwerke wo keiner weiß wie es
weitergeht während die kugeln um dem
einfliegen und gerade für diese
szenarien müssen wir unsere chemische
biologische und radioaktive nukleare
abwehr stärken sollte es zu dem
zwischenfall kommen jetzt rächt sich
unser verkürzte kleinkarierter blick auf
das thema verteidigung die ausrüstung
der bundeswehr es wichtig und richtig
aber jetzt gerade in diesem hybriden
bedrohungsszenario brauchen wir doch die
fähigkeiten des zivilschutzes und wer
hat den zivilschutz aus dem
sondervermögen herausverhandelt die
union und die union hat damit der
sicherheit des landes ein bärendienst
erwiesen
jetzt gilt es unsere eigenen ansprüche
als parlament die wir ja im
sondervermögen gesetzt eingeschrieben
haben nachzukommen wir sind der budget
gebe ja wir entscheiden am ende und weil
einige hier wild alle kompetenzen
durcheinander würfeln feuerwehr kommunen
land katastrophenschutz länder wir
machen den zivilschutz und auf diese
aufgabe sollten wir uns auch
konzentrieren
wir wollen uns handlungsfähiger mit
drohungen entgegen stellen und brauchen
deswegen einen starken zivilschutz
haushalt sehr geehrte kolleginnen
kollegen darum bitte ich um ihre
unterstützung im verfahren vielen dank
leon eckert war das und wir kommen zu
einem weiteren fraktionslosen
abgeordneten
mathias helferich auch beratendes
mitglied im indischen
damen und herren
diese worte veranlassten malte zwei
frauen am rande des münsteraner csds zu
hilfe zu eilen seine zivilcourage
bedeutete für ihn den tod der täter ein
abrupter kampfsportler schlug ihm
gezielt gegen den kopf er ging zu boden
und verstarb später im krankenhaus der
csd killer jura die iaa ist muslimischer
tschetschenen vorbestraft und
ausreisepflichtig wenige wochen zuvor
als die dortmunder polizei ein
vermeintlich 16 jährigen senegalesen der
sich und die polizisten mit einem messer
bedrohte aber der unterschied zwischen
beiden fällen ist es ist die hierarchie
der opfer wie es der autor martin nicht
nannte während sie schnell eine polit
mediale welle der empörung über die
erschießung des senegalesen formierte
mann der polizei strukturellen rassismus
attestierte und anti weiße kundgebung
organisierte schlägt das establishment
zur ermordung von walter bin deutsche
opfer und fremde täter sind vernimmt man
nur ohrenbetäubendes schweigen wofür
haben wir eigentlich ein früher
beauftragten der bundesregierung zehnten
gerade mal sehen sollen als er hess
vortrug da hat er nur mit dem kopf
geschüttet ich erwarte von ihm an eine
stellungnahme ein millionenschweres
integrationsprogramm keine millionen
förderung der deutschen islam konferenz
keine millionenschwere kampagne zur
förderung des ansehens unserer
sicherheitskräfte wird ein
gesellschaftliches kunstgebilde wie ihre
bunte republik zusammenhalten entwurzelt
fragmentiert von gegenseitiger fremdheit
geprägt und auch gewalttätig diese
unsichere zerfallenden gesellschaft ist
das produkt ihrer großen experimentellen
anordnung oder wie sie es nennen ihrer
großen transformationen ohne ihre große
transformation viele dieser
haushalterische pid überhaupt nicht
notwendig deutschland will keine
staatlich verordnete öffnung der
aufnahmegesellschaft kein resettlement
programm für afghanen kein schlachthaus
für tschetschenen werden und wenn sie
hier multikulturelles projekt weiter
verfolgen wollen dann sollten sie
wenigstens so ehrlich sein auch sie herr
emmerich und ihre regenbogen fahren um
die farbe blutrot ergänzen vielen dank
das ehemalige raf-mitglied
matthias helferich war dass ich für
diese
für die formulierung dass wir ein
schlachthaus sind so habe ich es
zumindest verstanden dafür ruhig sie
nächste rednerin für die spd-fraktion
peggy schierenbeck
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau ministerin nancy faeser
sehr geehrte damen und herren dieser
haushalt dieser einzelplan 06 ist
richtig und wichtig er ist das richtige
mittel um eine moderne und fortschritt
gewandte innenpolitik zu betreiben wir
stärken die bundespolizei mit
1009 stellen wir stärken das bka mit 180
9 stellen wir investieren in die
sicherheit aller menschen in unserem
land wir investieren auch in die cyber
sicherheit dieser bereich ist in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten so
wichtig geworden wie nie zuvor
im digitalen raum bestmöglich geschützt
zu sein ist so wichtig geworden wie nie
zuvor
ministerin henzler hat es eben bereits
betont die förderung unseren wir fördern
unser bevölkerungs und
katastrophenschutz
aus katastrophen zu lernen ist
essentiell jede flut jeder brandl die
dürre sollte uns anlass geben mehr in
uns schützende kräfte zu investieren
besser noch es gar nicht erst so weit
kommen zu lassen wir investieren auch
mehr in prävention
es wird uns einen klar sein aber ich
sage es gerne einmal prävention
verhindert mehr kosten als sie
verursacht prävention verhindert mehr
kosten als sie verursacht die politische
bildung ist schlüssel maßnahmen im kampf
gegen rechts die statistiken zeigen ist
uns das ist momentan die größte in der
gesellschaftliche bedrohung gegen die
wir mit allen mitteln vorgehen müssen
lassen sie uns auch weiter in die
prävention in kluge und langfristige
maßnahmen investieren mit diesem
haushaltsentwurf zeigen wir wie viel
fortschritt in der sicherheits- und
migrationspolitik möglich ist wir machen
einen großen schritt in richtung zukunft
wir machen deutschland zu einer modernen
gesellschaft mit diesem haushaltsentwurf
beweisen wir was alles möglich ist und
in welchem land wir leben wollen wir
beweisen dass wir zusammen stark sind
meine damen und herren der haushaltsplan
für das bundesministerium des inneren
und für heimat zeigt uns auch dass eine
wirksame innenpolitik auch funktionieren
kann wenn konjunktur mittel auslaufen
und die schuldenbremse wieder kreist
danke über martin wir sprechen hier von
sicherheit für alle cyber sicherheit
katastrophenschutz
politische bildung behörden unabhängige
asylverfahrens beratung
sportförderung präventionsarbeit wir
geben sicherheit wir halten die
gesellschaft zusammen wir schützen
unsere freiheit und unsere demokratie
vielen dank
[Applaus]